Ja, wollen wir anfangen?
Fangen wir an.
Wieder kein Jingle. Wieder immer noch kein Jingle, oder? Wir können ja dieses Lied trellern, was du da gerade gespielt hast. Das ist das schon totaler, wie sagt man? Ohrwurm, sagt man.
Das ist der totale Ohrwurm. Das wird jetzt erstmal nicht mehr los werden.
Again and again and again and again. Wenn man ja mal ganz stark mit Mac arbeitet, dann träumt man dann irgendwie davon, wie dann irgendwie Time Machine Fenster und Photoshop-Sequenzen.
So ohrwurmig war es doch gar nicht.
Total ohrwurmig. Das musst du noch mal ein zweites Mal hören.
Wir reden von... Wie heißt denn diese Lady eigentlich?
Ich muss das jetzt erstmal gerade mal raussuchen, weil ich das gerade nämlich versehentlich das Fenster zugemacht habe.
Aber gibst du... Du hast es bei Fake Steve Jobs gefunden.
Ich hab's bei Fake Steve Jobs gefunden und eben gerade nochmal bei Nerdcore.
So, so. Du liest also Fake Steve Jobs.
Fake Steve Jobs ist großartig. Wenn ich die Zeit dazu finde, ihn wirklich mal zu lesen, die Artikel, dann sind die sehr, sehr, sehr schön. Besonders die Analysen mag ich gerne.
Find ich auch. Ich find, der Typ hat echt...
Und ist so schon bissig.
Inside, ja. Großartig, oder? Vor allem so seine Lieblingsfeinde, so die anderen Journalisten, weil er ja selber einer ist. Und was sind seine Standards? Irgendwie Monkey Boy? Bäumer? Wie nennt er noch gleich den Google Vogel?
The Bird and the Bee heißt die Band übrigens.
The Bird and the Bee.
Das hab ich schon mal gehört letztens.
Wie heißt denn hier der Eric Schmidt von Google bei Fake Steve Jobs?
Der ist doch im Apple Board. Noch.
Ah, ich weiß nicht.
Monkey Boy ist Bäumer.
Monkey Boy ist Bäumer. Dann gibt es hier My Little Pony, hier der von Sun.
Den nennt er My Little Pony.
Ich glaub wegen der Frisur. Der wesentlich dadurch gelenzt hat, dass er einen Aktienzusammenführung hingelegt hat, damit der Aktienkurs über 10 Dollar ist.
Nein, er hat es auch geschafft, das Aktienkürzel in Java umzubenennen.
Von Sun W. Wo ich erst mal eh nicht rauskriegen musste, wofür denn das W steht.
Für Workstations steht das.
Das weißt du natürlich ganz von alleine.
Ich hätte das Sun W gelassen.
Na, jeder hätte das gelassen.
Das hätte jeder gelassen haben.
Ja, war ich meine, kalter Kaffee. Wie auch immer. Erst mal begrüßen. Hallo, hier ist Mobile Max. Ausgabe Nummer, äh, was denn?
Vier, vier glaube ich.
Echt?
Vier schon?
Ja. Ausgabe Nummer vier.
Boah, ich bin so ein Podcast-Profi.
Und wir haben hier Podcast-Profis versammelt. Zu linken Dennis. Hallo Dennis.
Hallo, ich bin Dennis.
Auf der rechten Seite Max. Und in der Mitte Tim.
Wir kommen ganz erholt aus dem Pfingstwochenende.
Hast du auch ein bisschen Urlaub gemacht? Ich hab mir die Sonne aufs Hauptschein lassen.
Ich auch und hab dabei verdrängt, dass ich Arbeit zu tun hätte gehabt.
Ja, zum Beispiel vorbereitendes Podcast.
Ach, das ist doch... Das ist eigentlich so gut verdrängt, dass ich das wirklich komplett vergessen hatte. Komm, ich hab mir auf den Weg hier ein Thema überlegt.
Wer wollte sich erst drücken? Na, na?
Ich wollte mich nicht drücken. Ich dachte nur, ich schaff's nicht rechtzeitig. Na was?
Hast du unsere kompletten Mondtags-Terminkalkulationen gemixt?
Wir müssen mal gucken, ob der Monat da eigentlich optimal ist. Die ganzen Apple-Announcments kommen eigentlich immer Dienstags.
Und wir sitzen an MacBook-Pros gibt's. Aber ich hab nicht mit rausgelassen.
Boah, das macht keinen Scheiß.
Wie? Aber immer noch das alte Gehäuse, nur ein bisschen schneller, blablibla blub.
Die machen ja schon Silent-Updates inzwischen.
Ich weiß nicht.
Hatte das nicht vor zwei Wochen auch schon so ganz silent, wie so nebenbei auf Heise erwähnt? Sonst hätte gar keiner rausgemerkt.
Bei den MacBook-Pro-Updates muss man auch silent sein, weil die sind ja alle nicht der Rede wert. Was haben die denn bitte schön geändert bei den Updates?
Multi-Touch angeblich.
Das ist aber schon eine Weile her, mein Freund.
Warte mal, bei MacBook-Pros? Oder ist mir jetzt bei Ihrem NetNews-Feier plötzlich ein alter Artikel wieder hochgekommen?
Ja, ja, den Effekt kenn ich, aber das ist...
Nee, das ist von heute. Was?
Aber heute ist doch Feiertag. Bei denen auch nicht, oder?
Nee, die haben den Artikel wieder gelöscht. Das war offensichtlich... Nee, ist doch heute Feiertag? Ich hatte auf jeden Fall heute ein neues Simpsons-Folge...
Ja, nee, also da bist du irgendwie...
Dann bin ich da komplett fehl... Nein, nein, das ist weg. Das ist weg. War auch nur bei Gizmodo, hat mich jetzt auch gewundert.
Das letzte Update war der neue iMac und da hat sich auch nicht sehr viel getan. Es ist halt ein bisschen fixer geworden, die Büchsen. Und der Mac Mini ist billiger und sie haben jetzt so komische... Erst hatten sie so komische Preise und die haben sie dann auch mal angepasst an das, was so üblich ist, so 99 hinten dran. Also der Mac Mini ist im Prinzip 100 Euro billiger geworden und der iMac ist schneller geworden. Ich weiß nicht, hatten wir das schon? 28.
April.
Ist ja auch total uninteressant. So was wollen wir ja gar nicht reden.
Aber vielleicht sollten wir das eben gerade, was ich gesagt habe, mal nutzen, um ein bisschen an exklusive Information reinzukommen, ein bisschen was auch zu einfach zu erfinden. Habt ihr den neuen Mac Pros gesehen mit 128 Ports?
Ich weiß nicht, ob das funktionieren soll. Jetzt, wo der mobile ist, hole ich mir vielleicht doch einen. Du musst davon ausgehen, dass unsere Hörer intelligenter sind als wir. Das heißt, wir können uns nur ins Entertainment retten.
Noch intelligenter?
Aber die könnten uns ja mal Top Secret Informations zuspielen.
Die könnten mal...
Wenn jemand bei der Telekom arbeitet oder bei Apple und sagt, wenn die neue iPhones rauskommen.
Wir müssen mal ein bisschen mit den Hörern schimpfen. Letztes Mal wollte ich nämlich eine Reaktion haben, wie wir denn bitte unsere Sendungen betiteln sollen. Und was kam? Nüscht. Viele interessante Kommentare, aber nichts zu der Frage, ob ich jetzt die Themen sammeln soll oder ob wir dem Ding einen Titel geben sollen. Ob wir es so machen sollen wie alle? Ja. Für mich ist das wichtig.
Aber gut, wenn sich die Leute nicht beschweren sind, sind sie zufrieden?
Ja, wahrscheinlich. So ist es.
Das wird sein.
Genau.
Dann müssen wir uns jetzt einen Titel für diese Sendung ausdenken.
Nein, das müssen wir nicht.
Nein, nein, nein.
Wir nehmen dann die Themen. Ach so, okay. Der Vorteil ist, warum ich das überhaupt mache, habe ich zuletzt mal schon erläutert. Der Grund ist, wenn man wirklich das als Podcast abonniert. Und...
Weiß man später nicht mehr am Datum, was das gewesen sein soll.
Ja, ich meine, es gibt so Podcasts, hier Spreeblick Podcasts zum Beispiel. Bestes Beispiel, habe ich Johnny auch schon vor Jahren mal gesagt. Das heißt, auf dem iPod geht man erstmal auf Spreeblick Podcasts. Dann kommt das so, dann steht da alle Episoden, der Titel und das Datum, was der iPod ja schon anblendet. Aber der Titel ist dann immer Spreeblick Podcast vom Datum. Also eine totale Null-Information. Das machen ganz viele. Das ist natürlich vollkommen bekloppt. Man will wissen, worum es geht. Man will einen Teaser haben.
Die haben es mit den Metainfos nicht so.
Weil das beim Spreeblick Podcast auch nicht ganz so einfach ist.
Wieso? Der weiß doch, worüber er redet. Der schreibt es doch auch in seinen Blog-Eintrag. Warum packt er das dann nicht gleich in den Titel? Stattdessen immer Podcast vom sowieso. Das sieht man ja auch im Blog-Eintrag sofort, wann das ist.
Mittlerweile ist es ja noch reduzierter. Da steht ja gar nicht mehr Podcast von. Da steht einfach nur noch das Datum.
Nur noch das Datum, was natürlich nochmal doppelt bekloppt ist. Weil dann steht sozusagen links das Datum und rechts das Datum.
Hört denn der Johnny unsere Sendung überhaupt?
Nein, bestimmt nicht.
Bestimmt?
Nein, ich glaube nicht.
Bestimmt nicht?
Der hat doch einen Mac oder nicht? Ich erzähl das, was meine Brüder gesagt haben.
Achso, er macht so ein Management Summary. Spielblick ist einfach so ein Konzern.
Ich druck den Podcast aus.
Da kann jetzt der Chef nicht irgendwie sich am Fuß folgen. Aber wir sind ja auch ein kommerzieller Podcast, hab ich in der Wikipedia gelesen.
Wir sind ein kommerzieller Podcast?
Ja.
Ich will mein Geld.
Musst du bei der Wikipedia beantragen. Da steht das drin. Das wäre ein kommerzieller Podcast. Ich kann da nicht sehr viel von merken, dass wir das sind. Wir sind einfach ein ganz normaler verwirrter Podcast, wie alle anderen. Aber wir versuchen auch interessante Informationen zu bringen. Genau. Und wenn wir uns mal die Nachrichtenlandschaft anschauen, dann werden wir um ein Thema nicht herumkommen. Auch wenn es sich weitgehend mit Gerüchteküche beschäftigt. Das iPhone kommt nicht nur in 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 Ländern, so wie wir es jetzt haben. Wie viele haben wir? Vier?
Amerika, England, Frankreich, Deutschland.
Vier.
Österreich.
Fünf.
Das iPhone gibt es offiziell? Nein, es gibt es in fünf Ländern.
Irland.
Irland? O2 darf jetzt auch in Irland verkaufen.
Österreich und Irland.
Österreich war die Extension für Deutschland, genau. Da hat es sich irgendwie nicht so richtig gelohnt, was eigenes zu machen. Also sagen wir mal so, vier bis sechs Länder. Und jetzt haben, ich hab keine Ahnung, ich hab jetzt aufgehört zu zählen, wie viele Telcos mittlerweile in Pressrelease rausgehauen haben, dass sie das iPhone verkaufen werden. Aber allein Vodafone wird in 16 Ländern antreten. Australien ist dabei, Singapur ist dabei, Indien ist dabei.
Ich hab da eine schöne Weltkarte gesehen.
Hab ich auch gesehen, aber ich weiß nicht mehr wo.
Mal sehen, wer als erstes eine hat. Ah, ich! Ha, ha, ha, ha. Zum Beispiel hier bei iPhoneBlock. Da unten ist sie.
Die sind informiert, wa?
Die sind super informiert. Also die ganze Welt ist schon rot?
Gar nicht.
Und die Schweiz ist isoliert.
Die Schweiz ist isoliert. Kuba ist noch grau.
Und Spanien ist gar nicht dabei.
Was in dieser Karte allerdings fehlt, ist die Information, wo mehr als ein Provider ist. Weil in Australien und in Italien und was noch ein anderes? Ich glaube nur die beiden Länder, zumindest nach dem aktuellen Kenntnisstand, gibt es mehr als einen Provider, der das iPhone führen soll. Und da steht natürlich die Frage, wird Apple seine Politik ändern? Tja, aber in was? Also ich glaube nicht, dass sie das Sim-Log...
Ich will mein iPhone wieder benutzen.
Das wollen wir alle, aber ich bin mir noch nicht so sicher, ob das nun das bedeutet. Weil zwei Provider im gleichen Land heißt nur, dass da sozusagen mehr als ein Provider das verkauft, aber die werden dann trotzdem immer noch gelockt sein. Aber wir wissen es nicht. Denn alles, was sie sagen ist, we are going to get you the iPhone later this year.
In so 3G-Version.
And later this year trägt... Also das ist so Steve Jobs all over, dieser Satz. Later this year. Das ist das, worum sie bitten und betteln durften, dass sie das schreiben dürfen.
Ich glaube teilweise nicht.
Oder? Ich sehe so richtig diese ganzen Telco-Chefs in so schwarzen Leder, over all, mit so einer Kugel im Maul. Alle kniend in einer Reihe vor Steve Jobs. Und dann kriegen sie die raus und dann dürfen sie irgendwie... Later this year sagen. Und dann dürfen sie later this year sagen.
Und für Leute, die nicht wissen, was es ist, müssen wir Perfection ein bisschen nach hinten spulen.
Ja, so läuft das, glaube ich. Das ist so eine SM-Veranstaltung. So ein Secret Meeting mit Steve Jobs, das hat einfach was mit es klar bereit.
Das ist der Grund, warum der Apple Campus unterkellert ist, oder?
Zu viele, die inzwischen irgendwie raus wollen mit der Info.
Also was mich gewundert hat bei diesem ganzen Announcement ist, die Länder, die sie schon letztes Jahr angekündigt haben, dass sie die machen werden, die sind noch nicht dabei. Japan. Also ich meine, da ist nicht Asia.
Die kommen ja auch nicht im Juni, die kommen ja später.
Man könnte sagen, dass Indien Asia ist, aber ich glaube, das würde dem indischen Subkontinent nicht so richtig...
Aber das ist das, was in drei Wochen kommt.
Wahrscheinlich sind die Japaner einfach noch ein bisschen disziplinierter und können die das dann anwenden?
Sagen wir doch mal, was hier überhaupt geht. Also Südamerika ist bis auf, was ist denn das da? Paraguay oder was haben sie da rausgelassen? Nee, das ist Bolivien und Venezuela, da dürfen sie auch nicht hin. Also die ganze Nordküste und so, aber der Rest, also Argentinien, Ecuador, Trinidad, da ist alles abgedeckt. Dann Kanada, Rogers, Weilis, wird es tun, was nicht groß verwundert. Es ist allerdings eine kleine Revolution in Kanada, weil die einfach unter extrem hohen Datentarifen bisher gelitten haben. Dann in Europa haben wir Portugal, komischerweise ist Spanien hier nicht dabei. Ich dachte, Spanien wär auch schon gecovert. Na ja, Türkei ist interessanterweise dabei und Griechenland, Italien, wie gesagt, zweimal.
Aber Moment mal, die Karte hier scheint, obwohl doch da ist Tschechien, okay.
Da unten ist doch die Verkreuzung.
Dominikanische Republik ist sogar dabei, kuck an. Jaja, ein Wunder. Also Europa ist nicht wirklich gut abgedeckt, was mich total verwundert, also Benelux, Dänemark, also auch so Länder, die einfach höllisch viel Geld haben. Was hält die? Vielleicht haben sie Angst vor Nokia.
Wahrscheinlich, oder?
Skandinavien haben sie einfach schon aufgegeben.
So böse subventioniert irgendwo.
Weiß ich nicht, da werden vielleicht Leute dann auf der Straße verfolgt, wenn sie irgendwie nicht mit Nokia rumlaufen, weil das nicht skandinavisch genug ist. Aber die sind ja eigentlich nicht so. Aber was mir fehlt, ist Japan.
Aber noch Australien und Neuseeland.
Ja, aber jetzt haben wir natürlich wieder unsere Recherche nicht gemacht. Wie sieht es da aus? Sogar Ägypten ist dabei.
Ägypten?
Ja, das ist Ägypten. Und Südafrika? Wie sieht es da wirklich mit UMTS aus? Mit der Versorgung meinst du? Das sind alles so Länder, die sind für mich nicht so UMTS-Länder. Also das, was viele Leute jetzt ableiten aus diesem Announcement, dass diese Ankündigung sozusagen auch der Grund ist, dass das UMTS-Phone kommt.
Aber es ist ja eine 2.0-Firma, da gibt es den 3G On-Off-Button. Wo noch drunter steht, dass man den ausschaltet, wenn man Batterie sparen will.
Das finde ich sehr interessant, Oes, dieses Feature. Dass man 3G ausschalten kann. Und das bedeutet, dass auch selbst der stromsparende Chip, den sie gedenken dort einzubauen, nicht so stromsparend ist wie GSM.
Ja, aber so richtig verstehe ich den Button nicht, weil ich meine, wenn ich gerade kein Datenzeugs mache, dann ist es doch eh aus.
GSM gibt es immer, naja, stimmt nicht. Bei uns gibt es das immer. In manchen Ländern gibt es das nicht immer. Also in Japan zum Beispiel gibt es kein GSM. Da gibt es diesen PCN Japan Kram und die gehen halt jetzt auch auf UMTS. Also mit UMTS habe ich selber in Japan.
Aber wirklich, wenn man es abschaltet, was?
Ja nichts, in Japan kann es sein, dass das Feature nicht an ist. Dass man das nicht abschalten kann, könnte ich mir vorstellen, aber Japan ist ja sowieso noch nicht auf der Liste.
Aber was wäre bei uns, wenn man es nicht auslässt?
Aber ich meine, da nimmt er halt GSM.
Aber es ist ja nicht nur für den Datenverkehr interessant. Man kann ja über UMTS auch telefonieren.
Ja, aber du kannst auch telefonieren, kannst aber auch mit GSM. Telefonieren mit UMTS ist nicht besser als das Telefonieren mit...
Dann würde ich es doch nur einschalten, wenn ich Daten-Calls mache.
Oder wenn du, wie ich, verhindern willst, dass das... in der Podcast-Aufnahme macht.
Ach. Das ist ein DSM-Geräusch?
Ja, mein Telefon liegt hier und das hat 3G und macht nicht...
Im Gegensatz zu diesem Gerät hier.
Genau, das macht nur... So ist das. Andere Frequenzen und so. Das geht dann alles mit UMTS.
Ich hoffe, dass das mal kommt.
Wow, es gab so ein Tschechen zu essen. Du hast eine gute Laune.
Oh, da gibt es leckere Sachen. Knetliky zum Beispiel ist total toll. Da gibt es so Knödel auch.
Wirklich?
Ja, da gibt es so richtig so in der Rolle und so.
Hast du seine Überwachungstechnik gesehen?
Dann gibt es auch diese lecker Waffeln, diese runden Teile, auch sehr nett.
Diese Oblaten?
Genau, die sind auch dünn.
Mit Schokolade dazwischen.
Also wir stellen fest, wir wissen immer noch nicht, ob das UMTS-Phone kommt, aber ich finde, es verdichtet sich.
Doch, es kommt.
Aber ob es für die Frage ist, kommt es im Juni, Juli. Ich meine, wenn jetzt so viele Telcos sagen Later this year, dann wird es doch bestimmt nicht mehr drei Monate dauern.
Also es bremst die Luft schon so dick, dass viele schon denken, dass es im Mai kommt. Also es heißt schon echt was.
Ich hab gestern bei Neuerdings gelesen...
Oh Gott, vielleicht kommt es gleich durch die Tür. Was wolltest du sagen, Max?
Ich hab gestern bei Neuerdings gelesen, dass irgendein Swiss von einer Schweizer Telefongesellschaft gesagt hat, nein, wir machen nur noch 3G-iPhone. Ich muss jetzt einen schönen Schweizer Dialekt hinkriegen, damit es Vertrauenswürdiger kriegt. Aber das 3G-iPhone... Egal. Also auf jeden Fall kriegen die nur das neue iPhone.
Wir können alle kein Schweizer Deutsch sprechen. Wenn das jetzt irgendwelche Schweizer hören, die legen sich jetzt schon wieder komplett weg. Hand in Hand, Gesicht in Hand. Berliner. Wir können ja noch nicht mal richtig Berlinern.
Klar kann ich.
Echt?
Klar, ich bin ja richtiger Berliner.
Na mach mal.
Mach ich doch die ganze Zeit.
Ist doch nicht dein Ernst.
Reicht doch.
Na hier, Konstanze, die Berliner.
Ja, Frauen.
Naja.
Ne, außerdem alle.
Ne, aber ohne Ausnahme.
Die Ost-Berliner sind noch ein bisschen härter im Dialekt. Muss ich dazu hin.
Das ist wahr. Wenn viele richtig loslegen, dann wächst auch kein Gras mehr.
Ja, ich kann es leider nicht.
Aber bist du doch, was, in der Schule? Ja, du bist doch hier unser Quoten-Zoni. Die 33%-Quote.
Ost-Berliner?
Ja.
Was? Quatsch, du bist vom Land.
Hallo, ich hab, hallo? Also ich will, hatten wir das nicht schon mal? Ich bin, ich bin...
Ja, wir hatten das schon mal, aber du hast nicht gesagt, wo du her bist.
Guck mal, stolpert sein Reden.
Machs den Bock auf.
Ich bin geboren in Rüdersdorf.
Aha.
Rüdersdorf?
Rüder.
Rüdersdorf.
Rüders, oh Gott.
Das ist kurz vor Erkner, hinter Woltersdorf.
Kiek an. Ja.
Und das ist noch nicht Land. Und da bin ich auch wirklich nur geboren worden. Wirklich, wirklich, wirklich, wirklich.
Ist ja in Ordnung, ich bin auch in so einem Kaff geboren worden.
Ach, ja. Ach.
Nein, ich bin in einem richtigen Kaff geboren worden.
Außerhalb von Hannover?
Also Hannover ist auch ein richtiges Kaff.
Außerhalb von Hannover, verstehst du? Das klingt weit weg, oder? Das ist nicht nur so die andere Galaxis, sondern auch noch dann so...
Dahinter.
Ja, in einem mit verlegenen Spiralarm so.
Da ist ja Luke Skywalker nah dran geboren.
Jenseits der Messbarkeitsgrenze. Südersdorf bei Berlin.
So, jetzt schieb mal wieder ein Thema hier in die...
Du meinst, wir sollen uns mal wieder was weginteressieren?
Nein, nein, nein, Moment mal, ich war hier noch bei... Wann kommt das iPhone nach Ödersdorf? Die Schweizer haben gesagt, dass sie erst das 3G-iPhone haben wollen. Es gibt in ganz Amerika keine iPhones mehr im Laden zu kaufen, nicht mehr mehr im Apple Store, wo man bisher noch mit ein bisschen Glück welche bekommen haben. Es gibt in Großbritannien keine iPhones mehr zu kaufen, bis sie mal wieder geliefert werden.
Aber es gab schon mal so eine Shortage und die war dann wieder vorbei. Die lag nur an einer großen Nachfrage.
Ist die Nachfrage gerade groß, weil jetzt wo ein 3G kommen soll, rennen noch nicht alle los und kaufen sich schnell noch das Alte?
Ich glaube, dass die Leute, die wenigstens, es mag viele Leute geben, die jetzt darauf warten, die ganzen Nerds, aber die meisten Leute, die für ein iPhone entscheiden, die denken nicht wirklich so in die Richtung.
Aber es ist bei AT&T aufgekauft, aufgetaucht, das iPhone Black. Plötzlich. Wo ist das aufgetaucht? In den Support-Dokumenten. Das kann man hier schön sehen. Und hier schön sehen.
iPhone Black. Ach, du meinst dann dieser Mock-Up, wo das Ding so einen schwarzen Rücken hatte, war doch kein Fan?
Doch, das glaube ich schon.
Ich hoffe nicht, dass es in diesem Weiß rauskommt, wie in diesem Pflaster-iPod-Style.
Du meinst, die lassen das schöne Metall weg und machen das schwarz?
Bitte nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht so ein bisschen mehr wie so ein iPod Touch. Wie sieht denn der von hinten eigentlich aus?
Vielleicht haben sie einfach auch so ein WLAN. Wie ist denn eigentlich die WLAN-Reception auf dem Teil? Ist die so gut wie auf dem MacBook?
Ich würde sagen, besser ein bisschen.
Besser noch? Ja, also ich hab das stört, also nicht mit dem Metall.
Nee, dafür ist ja unten das Pflaster.
Also ich bin mit dem WLAN-Empfang ziemlich glücklich. Also ich hab auch schon wahre Horror-Märchen gehört, aber du bist im Unglück eher unglücklich, wenn ich das so richtig mitbekomme.
Was hast du denn gemacht?
Ich hab mein iPhone auf eine neueste Version gebrickt.
Jetzt neu das iPhone Brick. Weil ich es nicht abwarten konnte.
Version, ich weiß gar nicht, ich kann mal schnell nachgucken, damit die Leute nicht den gleichen Fehler machen wie ich. Und zwar habe ich die Version 5A274D eingespielt. Das ist so eine Developer-Version, und die ist jetzt auch schön drauf und so. Aber die ist halt nicht unlockt, und ich habe nur zwei Karten, und deswegen geht jetzt nichts mehr.
Und jetzt musst du wieder mit dem Nokia rumlaufen.
Ja, voll doof.
Geht aber auch, oder?
Ist so uncool.
Wer braucht schon Internet?
Na ja, aber ich bin nicht mehr so cool wie vorher.
Das stimmt. Das sieht man auch.
Ich merke das auch.
Ja, ich auch.
Das wird hier evident. Tja, Dennis. Aber war schön, dass du da warst.
Ja, du stinkst auch schon so ein bisschen.
Ich kriege das schon wieder hin.
Ja, also viel Glück beim Wiederherstellen. Wir haben es gerade noch mal auf meinem Rechner probiert, ging auch nicht. Im Augenblick scheint da keiner.
Muss man warten, bis das iPhone Dev Team mal aus der Tasche kommt. Die schnarchen immer so ein bisschen mit ihren Updates.
Na ja, die haben ja auch was anderes zu tun.
Die sind Hacker. Die haben nichts anderes zu tun.
Ja, das stimmt allerdings.
Und hier der Syphon Mensch, der hat...
Der labert ja auch schon rum. Das würde dauern, wenn es rauskommt, weil es schwierig und bla. Aber da gibt es ja eh die Story, dass der Typ eigentlich gar keine Ahnung hat. Und deswegen sagt er natürlich auch, dass da nichts rauskommt, oder dass es länger dauert. Wobei er ja auch ganz schön postt auf seiner Seite mit irgendwie Screenshots und Zeug.
Wollen wir noch davor warnen, dass Leute einen Firmware-Update machen?
Also wir können auch viel zu davor warnen, mit Raubkopierter Beta-Software.
Also wenn man keine Ahnung hat, soll man es halt irgendwie nicht machen. Und wenn man Ahnung hat, dann soll man vorher gucken, dass es irgendwie anlockt ist und danach auf jeden Fall immer noch funktioniert.
Was gab es denn da noch für Verheißungen in der aktuellen 2.0-Version, die auf neue Features schließen lassen?
Na es gibt ja diesen Push-Email-Button.
Sehr interessant. Hat aber noch keiner gesagt, was da jetzt wirklich so dahintersteckt, was sie da machen.
Also richtig, hab ich sowieso noch nie kapiert, muss ich mal ganz ehrlich sagen. Kann mich jetzt mal einer aufdenken, was Push sein soll, weil es soll ja irgendwie schonender sein im Abrufen, weil Blackberry haben es ja auch. Aber was ist denn da drin jetzt so das Problem, irgendwie ab und zu mal nachzufragen, ob deine neue Email für mich da ist?
Du hältst einfach eine Datenverbindung auf. Also normalerweise ist es ja so, hier ist mein Rechner und mein kleines Email-Programm, fragt alle fünf Minuten nach, oder alle zehn Minuten, oder in regelmäßigen Abständen, du hast was Neues für mich, und dann sagt die Gegenstelle, ja, hab was Neues für dich, ja, hast du, oder im meisten Fall, nee, hab nichts Neues für dich. Und bei diesen ganzen Push-Verfahren ist das feine, dann wird eine Datenverbindung aufgemacht, die bleibt die ganze Zeit offen, aber dadurch, dass sie höchstens hin und her ein kleines Idle-Signal schicken muss.
Das heißt, da werden keine Programme neu gestartet oder Prozesse oder Services oder Sockets hochgezogen, sondern es ist einfach die ganze Zeit da und deswegen ist es so sparsam.
Es ist so sparsam, weil es werden keine Daten übertragen in den meisten Fällen.
Eine SMS ist auch Push. Weil das Netz sagt, hallo Telefon, und die stehen ja die ganze Zeit in Verbindung.
Ja, aber dann muss man ja auch die Datenverbindung die ganze Zeit offen haben.
Das Netz und das Telefon haben ja die ganze Zeit eine Datenverbindung.
Das geht ziemlich auf den Akku. Also so Push mehr geht, ich hab das damals auf meinem Sony K800.
Ja, wenn es auf den Akku geht, was ist denn der Vorteil?
Moment, der Vorteil ist, guck mal, die Leute, die so was, die Push-Email verwenden, verwenden E-Mail halt quasi in Realtime. Die gehen davon aus, dass wenn sie jemand anders eine E-Mail schicken, dass die auch in dem Moment sofort ausgeliefert wird, wie eine SMS.
Und die kommt sofort an.
Das ist unglaublich. Weil die ganzen Manager-Typen so ganz hip sein wollen, die wollen halt instant E-Mail, und wenn die alle 10 Sekunden irgendwie E-Mail abrufen würden, würden die Server zusammenbrechen und deswegen meldet sich der Server, wenn eine E-Mail da ist.
Nö, es wäre viel aufwendiger, dass ein Telefon alle 10 Sekunden fragt, ist was da, ist was da, ist was da, ist was da, anstatt dass sie einfach...
Der Server sagt, jetzt ist was da.
Ja, ich meine, es gibt im IMAP auch ein Feature für Realtime Notifications, dieses Idle-Feature, und das muss man einfach nur implementieren.
Vermutlich ist das exakt das, was dieses IMAP-Push darstellt.
Kann ich mir auch schon vorstellen. Zumindest die Firmen wie Yahoo, die ein bisschen internet savvy sind, werden sich jetzt nicht was komplett Neues aus der Nase ziehen.
Apple Mail unterstützt das meines Wissens mittlerweile auch von vornherein dieses IMAP-Push-Verfahren. Auf jeden Fall gibt es eine Checkbox dafür, auch wenn ich die noch nie so richtig in Aktionen gesehen habe. Ach wirklich? Seit 10.05 gibt es in Mail, jetzt müssen wir noch von Screenshots veröffentlichen, oder?
Du musst jetzt genau für mich zum Mitschreiben sagen, wo es ist und die User können ja jetzt schon mal ihr Mail-Programm starten.
Ich muss es mal selber gucken.
Die User haben jetzt ihr Mail-Programm offen.
Ich hab's schon.
Ich auch.
Ich bin ready.
Ah, genau. Es gibt unter Einstellungen Accounts dann ein IMAP-Account anklicken. Und da gibt's Erweitert, den haben wir den letzten Tag. Und ganz unten steht die Checkbox.
Use idle command if the server supports it.
Hab ich alle aber.
Hab ich auch an. Das ist Default.
Müssen wir mal rausgucken, welche Gegenstände da sind.
Das brauch ich. Ich muss sofort meinen Admin anrufen.
Darf ich mal kurz?
Mein Telefon klingelt. Wo ist mein Telefon?
Also ich weiß... Ich weiß, dass der Spreeblick-Server das unterstützt, die das Push verhaftet. Was habt ihr für einen IMAP-Server? Das ist ein Courier, glaube ich. Hab ich doch auch, verdammt! Echt, der Courier?
Ich hatte früher total viele Probleme mit einem Courier, IMAP-Server.
Das Leute sagen, der wäre nicht langsam.
Ich hatte auch so Kompatibilitätsprobleme. Aber seitdem ich... Der ist vielleicht noch der andere?
Also ich bin ein großer Freund von Cyrus, falls du den nimmst.
Ja, der auch. So war es.
Genau. Den habe ich auch schon ein paar Mal aufgesetzt. Aber da ich keinen Bock hatte, wieder drei Tage rein zu investieren, hier einen blöden Mail-Server aufzusetzen und dann mit Sassl und weiß der Teufel, was habe ich die Plask-Installation, die dabei war, genommen?
Warum nimmst du denn nicht einfach Mac OS X Server, wie sich das für einen richtigen Macintosh-Nerd gehört? Ich kenne so wenig Leute, die das einsetzen.
Weil, geh mal zu einem erfolgreichen großen Provider und sag, dass du gerne Mac OS X auf deinen Rechnern hättest. Ich glaube, die lachen dich erstmal leicht aus, wenn du auch ein genauso gutes Dekor haben kannst.
Es gibt so Mac Mini-Hosts da, die haben da so eine Batterie von Mac Minis drin und da kannst du dann irgendwie deine OS X Server drauf werfen.
Das sind wohl zu, ehrlich gesagt.
Das ist schön. Ich hab derzeit gar keinen Server, weil ich noch davon gutiere, dass mir andere Leute Dienste bereitstellen. Aber ich denke ernsthaft darüber nach. Da können wir gleich nochmal separat kommen. Mac OS X Server, ich hab jetzt mit den letzten Versionen nicht so viel Erfahrung gesammelt. Ich überleg aber auch, ob ich mir so ein Mac Mini hier zu Hause hinstelle und mir dann Internetzugang zulege, der so IP-Adresse geht jetzt erstmal nicht um E-Mails, sondern die anderen Sachen. Aber sie haben das so mit dem Admin-Interface schon ganz gut hinbekommen. Also für einen Unix-Server ist das schon ziemlich cool. Du kannst irgendwie alle Services auf einen Blick sehen, was läuft, was nicht da. Es gibt echt eine Menge Mail und Mailing-Listen und Jabba-Server und Pipapo, also Fileservices.
Also wofür es natürlich ganz toll ist jetzt mit diesem CalDAF-Verfahren, mit 10.5.
Genau, darauf finde ich nämlich zum Beispiel scharf, weil ich will nämlich endlich mal einen Kalenderserver für zu Hause haben, damit man hier in der Familie auch mal seine Termine abgestimmt bekommt, weil das nämlich echt nicht einfach. Gerade ist kein Kind. Und so mit Kalender-Items hin und her schicken per E-Mail, da wirst du irgendwann total wahnsinnig.
Nein, also dieses CalDAF-Verfahren ist schon sehr schick auf jeden Fall.
Hast du das schon mal benutzt?
Nicht wirklich. Also ich habe da auch eine Open Source-Implementierung bei uns auf den Server aufgesetzt gehabt.
Die von Apple?
Nee, die habe ich nicht zum Laufen bekommen.
Weil das Ding von Apple ist nämlich offener Soße.
Ich weiß, dass es das gibt. Irgendwo konnte man sich runterladen. Ich habe es auch mal spaßeshalber installiert, aber es lief dann so halb und nicht so richtig. Also es gibt da noch nicht so eine schöne Out of the Box-Lösung für CalDAF. Wobei ich auch mit Mac OS X Server ein paar Probleme hatte, was zum Beispiel besonders nervt. Man muss am Anfang bei der Installation den Ding einen Namen geben und den kann man dann nie wieder ändern.
Was ist das letzte Mac OS X Server, was du in der Hand hattest? Tatsächlich, 10.5 Server. Hatte ich noch nicht in der Hand.
Und ist so alles, da ist ein hübsches Wiki dabei und alles sowas, aber so in Detail, oder was heißt nicht in Detail, aber so diese ganzen Pakete wie, was weiß ich was, ImageMagic, was bei einem Debian Upget Install ImageMagic ist, ist, oder auf jedem Linux ist bei Mac OS X ein kleineres Drama, das zu installieren. Diese ganze Paketverwaltung.
Aber dafür gibt es doch MacPorts.
Dafür gibt es doch MacPorts.
Jetzt guck mal, war das nicht unauffällig?
Ja, also vielleicht nochmal kurz zum Mac OS X Server. Ich finde das an sich ganz cool. Für so kleine Work Groups ist das keine schlechte Sache, weil sie haben da einfach eine Menge Sachen drauf und wenn man sich das leisten kann, sich auch einen ordentlichen Internetzugang entweder in ein Büro hinzulegen oder dass man wirklich so einen Teil beim Host da hinstellt. Andere Leute tragen auch ihre eigenen Rechner zum Host, da kann man auch einen Macintosh hintragen. Es muss ja nicht immer gleich ein X Server sein, obwohl ein X Server natürlich noch zahlreiche andere Vorteile hat. Du kannst auch alles wunderbar monitoren und hast gleich so ein schickes Admin Tool mit den Platten und rein raus. Es geht alles ganz nett. Aber es ist natürlich jetzt nicht vom Preis her nicht ganz so konkurrenzfähig wie die anderen Sachen.
Aber es ist halt so ein Denk-nicht-drüber-nach-Feature. Ich hab mal einen richtig schönen X Server, damals noch mit G5, bei einer Firma im Einsatz mit installiert und den haben wir dann eingebaut und haben auch ein richtiges offizielles X-Ray dazugeholt. Das ist schick. File Sharing ist super und wenn die jetzt Backups erstellen wollen ins Netzwerk, dann geht das hoffentlich auch alles super mit Time Machine und so was. Wenn sie es dann irgendwann mal schaffen, das Update auf 10.5 einzuspielen, was natürlich noch so eine andere Sache ist, aber wenn es darum geht, so einen Web-Server zu haben, im Wesentlichen, wo ein bisschen Mail draufläuft und vielleicht ein bisschen WebDAF und ein bisschen SSH, muss es dann wirklich ein Mac OS 10 werden?
Nee, muss es nicht sein. Ich finde es dann eine gute Lösung, wenn man schon so einen Rechner haben will, der dann mal so zwei, drei, vier, fünf Dienste anbietet, die alle so insgesamt nicht so ohne weiteres immer in den Griff zu kriegen sind. Mail-Server-Setup zum Beispiel, da echt jeder, den ich kenne, setzt doch mal einen Mail-Server auf. Gibt es nicht andere Sachen, ich wollte einen Urlaub, ich habe nichts gehört, dumm die dumm, na nein, meine Oma ist gerade gestorben. Das geht halt da relativ easy.
Aber da bin ich mit Plest, wie gesagt, relativ glücklich. Was ist das? Das ist so eine, ich weiß nicht wie die heißt, eine SW-Soft oder so eine Firma, das ist eigentlich ein Server-Administrationstool, Web-Oberfläche und die bringen halt einen Haufen Pakete mit, eine Standardinstallation und installiert man. Gibt es auch schön für Debian, das sind die Source-Eintricks, dann installierst du PSA, heißt das dann, glaube ich, und danach hast du einen Server, also hast du einen Apache, unter deren Kontrolle hast du...
Wie adnistrisst du das?
Über das Web-Interface. Ich bin damit glücklich und zufrieden. Und es hat seine kleinen Macken. Kann sein.
Ich finde ja immer so Produkte, die nicht nur ein Web-Interface haben, sondern so richtig ein ordentliches Protokoll mit einer ordentlichen GUI ab, das rockt einfach mehr. Da hast du irgendwie deinen Dreck und Drop, da hast du irgendwie deinen Copy und Paste, da hast du irgendwie einfach ein ordentliches User-Interface. Keine Ahnung, von meinem iPhone aus, da müsste ich ja erstmal ein iPhone haben.
Stimmt.
Wie auch immer. Also, ich finde das auf jeden Fall gelungen. Da hat sich immer wieder was verbessert und du hast vor allem auch eine ganze Menge Sachen so out of the box, irgendwie so Zertifikat-Management für deinen Web-Server und sowas, einfach alles mit Command-Line-Administration, immer ein Gemuckel und ein Gefummel ist. Das geht einfach. Ich habe so problemlos mal so 10, 20 Websites auf diesem Rechner verwaltet, ohne jetzt wirklich viel Blickung zu haben von den Details und Untiefen der Apache-Konfiguration. Ich kann zwar so ein Apache so, mal so eben wenn es sein muss, auch aufsetzen und so 2, 3, 4, 5 Sachen ändern, aber wenn man nicht wirklich, verstehst du, wenn man nicht wirklich so dedizierter Admin ist. Du bist ja auch Admin, ja?
Jetzt hier nicht beschimpfen.
Warum ist denn das eine hoch angesehene Dienstleistung auf diesem Planeten?
Ja, aber ich bin kein Admin. Also ich will auch kein Admin sein.
Du willst vielleicht kein Admin sein, aber du administrierst viel zu viele Subsysteme als das überhaupten könntest, du wärst keiner. Wärts heute. Wie auch immer. Admins, verstehst du, die machen das sozusagen auch als Daily Business? Es ist ihr Business, die beschäftigen sich damit, die haben dann ihr Setup und natürlich finden sie aber irgendwas, was einfacher ist. Aber jetzt so ein normaler Power-User auf dem Mac, der eben auch mal einen Server haben will und der braucht mal eine Mailinglist, der braucht mal eine neue Website, der will hier nochmal ein Zertifikat installieren und der ist mit so einem Mac OS X Server ganz gut bedient, finde ich.
Genau das hatte ich leider auf dem Mac OS X Server nicht. Also mit besagter Domain, dass man beim Hochfahren des Dings muss man den Domain eingeben und auf der reagiert er dann und die kann man nicht im Nachhinein irgendwo ändern, über ein Kontrollfeld und damit ist man damit gefangen. So richtig schick hab ich das noch nicht hinbekommen. Ich hab noch nicht gefunden, welche z.B. wenn man eine VPN-Verbindung aufmachen muss, welche Ports muss ich öffnen im Router, damit er dann die interne, den internstehenden Mac OS X Server auch findet. Solche Sachen sind...
Stimmt, VPN hab ich auch nicht hinbekommen. Das war auch noch ein 10.3 Server, deswegen weiß ich nicht, wie sich das entwickelt hat.
Also das ist, da sind, wie gesagt, da sind großartige Sachen dabei. Da ist zum Beispiel diese Wiki-Software, die wirklich toll aussieht, die Ajaxi ist und weiß der Teufel was. Da ist dieses Calderf, was relativ gut funktioniert. Aber da sind auch ein Haufen Sachen, die eher nervig sind. Also zum Beispiel jetzt seitdem wir diesen Mac OS X Server da rumstehen haben, auch auf einem Mac Mini, fährt regelmäßig bei mir diese Verzeichnungsdienstesoftware hoch und will meinen Rechner konfigurieren auf den Server, was ich überhaupt nicht möchte. Und ich hab keinen blassen Schimmer, wo ich das bei der Kiste abstelle. Und ich finde, sowas sollte ein Default-Off sein. Und so ein paar Kleinigkeiten, die ich so finde, naja, die könnten ruhig ein bisschen besser sein. Von Apple erwarte ich da etwas mehr.
Mal schauen, vielleicht mach ich das demnächst. Jetzt ist der Mac Mini ja auch billiger geworden. Ich bin tempted, wie man so schön sagt, auf Neudeutsch.
Tempted? Versucht.
Versucht.
Da steckt so Temptation dahinter. Ach doch, gleich so weit.
Ja, na guck mal, ich hab ja noch so einen neuen Bildschirm hier stehen. Der ist hier einfach so nackt. Und er wartet einfach da drauf, von irgendeinem Mini beglückt zu werden.
Da die jetzt ja billiger geworden sind, ne?
Da sie billiger geworden sind.
Eigentlich muss man. Es wäre dumm, wenn nicht.
Aber leider, ich würde halt ganz gerne auch mal sehen, dass diese Mac-Minis ein bisschen mehr kriegen. Mehr war es nicht. Aber ist wahrscheinlich schnell genug. Wie auch immer. Jetzt, wo du das vorhin mit ImageMagic angesprochen hast. MacPorts.
Du schreibst mit, welche Themen wir gerade offen haben, oder? Du machst eine Klammer auf. Also ich probiere das ja gerade aus und ein bisschen.
Über Mac OS X Server haben wir jetzt gerade geredet.
Das iPhone haben wir noch ein bisschen offen.
Nö, was haben wir denn da noch offen? Ich hab da nichts drauf.
Fake Steve Jobs haben wir noch nicht so richtig abgeschlossen, oder?
Was soll man dazu sagen? Also Fake Steve Jobs. Wer das jetzt nicht kennt, der soll sich mal das Fake Steve Jobs Webblog anschauen. Das ist lustig, aber mehr muss man dazu auch nicht sagen.
Aber wir wollten noch mal unseren kleinen Microsoft-Kampf von der letzten Woche wieder aufwärmen.
Da wollten wir noch einen Nachtrag liefern, aber du hast jetzt gerade die Sache mit den MacPorts angesprochen.
Geh ich da mal drauf ein. Ich wollte nur, dass wir den Überblick nicht verlieren.
Ich verlier den Überblick nie.
Das war sehr gut. Oh!
Ja, das habe ich mit diesem general scharfen Schallglick gesagt. Apropos. Na ja, also die Sache mit dem Unix. Das ist ja so ein Ding. Und wo du so schön Linux-Suite gesagt hast, da habe ich mein Up-Get-Image-Magic und alles ist prima. Ports gibt es halt auch auf dem Mac. Und das ist auch nichts Neues. Die Ports gibt es schon eine Weile. Aber die fristen natürlich schon so ein bisschen so ein zweiter Reihe, zweite Klasse.
Die leben im Underground, im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes.
Das tun sie.
Aber die MacPorts sind doch eigentlich noch relativ neu, weil früher gab es doch dieses Fink und noch diese Darwin-Ports, oder wie hießen die früher? Sind eigentlich die MacPorts, die Darwin-Ports?
Genau, das wäre jetzt mal eine Frage gewesen.
Ja, also sind sie. Also Mac OS 10 kam raus und die Leute, die Freunde der Kommando-Zeile, wollten halt gerne Ports haben. Ports sind kurz gesagt vorkonfigurierte, eine Sammlung von, ja, eine, wie soll ich sagen, eine notierte Anweisung wie ein Open Source Projekt, was im Netz im Source Code vorliegt, heruntergeladen werden kann und wie man es dann auf dem Rechner übersetzt, so dass es dort läuft. Dieser Vorgang des Runterladens, des Übersetzens und Installierens, das ist das, was ein Portsystem übernimmt.
Und gerade am Anfang von Fink war ja noch sehr wichtig, auch das Patchen der jeweiligen Source, damit es überhaupt auf Mac OS X läuft.
Das ist überall wichtig.
Und natürlich das Management des Ganzen halt, die da Ports deinstallieren oder Abhängigkeiten resolven.
Genau, Abhängigkeiten, alles was halt dazugehört. Weil das ist ja alles nicht so einfach. Früher war das so, man musste sich halt was runterladen, und dann musste man irgendwie mehrere Tage damit verbringen, irgendwelche If-Devs in den Source Code einzutragen, um das eben auf der eigenen Plattform zum Laufen zu kriegen. Weil eben two Unixes are not alike. Das gibt einfach nix, was so ein Unix Standard ist.
Aber man muss schon sagen, dass es auch immer besser wird.
Es wird besser, aber es ist halt immer noch eine ganze Menge zu machen. Gerade Mac OS X hat gegenüber den anderen Unix-Systemen nochmal ein paar signifikante Unterschiede. Zum Beispiel wie die Dynamic Libraries. Bei Mac OS X ist halt alles dynamic. Das Binding funktioniert dann im Detail anders und so weiter. Es gibt halt auch viele Annahmen, die in so Open Source-Projekten mit drin sind, weil sie eben meistens nur in der Linux eingesetzt werden. Und wenn die dann überhaupt schon mal auf BSD treffen, dann ist es schon mal ein bisschen anders. Und bei Mac OS X ist es dann nochmal irgendwie anders. Trotzdem, soweit sie sich an Posix halten, geht das irgendwie. Aber wenn man halt ganz genau hinschaut und wenn es wirklich auch stabil und zuverlässig übersetzen soll, muss man eben so einiges tun. Und das machen halt Ports. Das heißt, ein Port ist nichts anderes als ein Sammelsurium aus Anweisungen, wie, wo kriegt man die Source kurz her. Eine oder mehrere Dateien müssen aus dem Internet runtergeladen werden. Wo kommen die her? Sind die von SourceForge und so weiter? Das Runterladen von SourceForge automatisch ist nicht so einfach wie von einem FTP-Server und so weiter. Da steht da alles drin. Und wenn ich dann irgendwie auf der Command-Seite sage, Make Port, also installieren wir mal jetzt diesen Port, wie das auch immer funktioniert. Also bei MacPorts würde ich dann schreiben, sudo port install portname. ImageMagic war dein Beispiel. sudo port install imagemagic. Dann geht er los und schaut sich das Port-File an. Das hast du halt vorher mit dem Port-System installiert. Und da steht dann drin, ImageMagic gibt es irgendwie da und da. Da musst du die und die Datei runterladen. Dann lädt er die runter. Dann patcht er die. Das heißt, er hat unter Umständen auch eine Reihe von Patch-Files dabei. Wendet die dann automatisch an, sprich modifiziert den Source-Code. Dann übersetzt er ihn, erzeugt ein Binary, das dann noch nicht gleich installiert wird, sondern der Installations... Das ist eine Eigenschaft von den MacPorts, dass das so ein mehrstufiger Prozess ist. Erst bildest du das. Dann liegt das Binary in so einem Bild-Direktorie. Dann wird das gestaged. Das heißt, es wird installiert, aber es ist noch nicht wirklich verfügbar. Du kannst mehrere Versionen des gleichen Ports installiert haben. Das ist eine MacPorts-Eigenschaft in diesem Fall. Du kannst mehrere installiert haben, sodass sie sozusagen ready to run wären, aber die sind dann noch nicht so richtig verlinkt. Dann kannst du zwischen verschiedenen Versionen eines Ports noch durch Activate und Deactivate hin- und herschalten, was manchmal ganz praktisch ist. MacPorts hieß früher Darwin Ports, weil das sozusagen für Darwin gemacht war. Das ganze Darwin-Projekt ist nie so richtig in die Gänge gekommen. Es war noch ein bisschen die Vision, ok, alles klar, Darwin ist Open Source, aber Mac OS 10 nicht, dann nehmen wir jetzt mal Darwin für voll als eigenständiges Betriebssystem. Dann gab es auch dieses Open Darwin-Projekt, was sich auf die Fahnen geschrieben hat, dass sie das eben so distributieren wie ein Linux. Oder ein BSD. Das ist komplett zusammengefallen, weil sie einfach nicht mehr genug Leute gefunden haben. Das hat auch ein bisschen was damit zu tun, wie Apple das Projekt unterstützt hat oder nicht unterstützt hat im Detail. Weiß ich jetzt auch nicht genau, was da abgegangen ist, aber die sehen da einfach keine Zukunft mehr. Es gibt einfach auch niemanden, der an dem Darwin-Könnel arbeitet. Also außer Apple arbeitet niemand an diesem Darwin-Könnel. Es gibt einfach keine Darwin-Könnel-Hacker da draußen. Und das ist natürlich für so ein Projekt eigentlich deadly.
Wollen die aber Apple anscheinend auch nicht so richtig?
Ach, es ist doch, soweit ich das gehört habe, hätten die schon nichts dagegen, wenn irgendwelche besonders talentierten Hacker sind. Bloß, es ist halt so, wer wirklich gut im Kernel hacken ist, der geht natürlich eher in so ein Projekt, wo du sehr viel mehr im Media-Recognition hast. Da bist du bei FreeBSD oder OpenBSD. Da kannst du dich ganz anders einbringen. Da weißt du auch einfach, wie das mit den Release-Zyklen sind so demokratische Systeme. Und das einzig sinnvolle Distributionssystem ist halt Mac OS X und da hat dann einfach keiner irgendwie eine Hand drauf. Und das ist natürlich frustrierend. Von daher richtig ambitionierte Kernel-Hacker gehen zu anderen Projekten und da bleibt dann eben für Apple einfach nichts mehr übrig. Naja, so, das ist halt das Ding. Du kannst halt deine Port-Liste immer wieder aktualisieren und da sind die ganzen Dependencies drin. Das heißt, das Image-Magic, da holt sich dann eben auch die ganzen anderen Libraries und so weiter pipa-pum.
Ja, aber das funktioniert alles. Also was ich an MacPorts auszusetzen habe, man kriegt immer nur eine Source und nie einen Binary-Install. Das ist theoretisch ganz hübsch, dass das alles auf meiner Kiste übersetzt wird. Interessiert mich aber ehrlich gesagt nicht die Bohne, sondern ich hätte gerne eine Binary-Version, die dann auch relativ schnell einfach installiert ist. Und das ist in der Praxis leider nicht ganz so perfekt funktioniert, wie ich habe jetzt mal genau dieses Pseudoport-Install-Image-Magic eingegeben, was ich vor einiger Zeit schon mal gemacht habe. Und das endet mit der Fehlermeldung, Figure Aga Error EJG JPEG Library not found in OptLocalLib. Und ich weiß nicht, was ich weitermachen soll.
Hast du mal ein Pseudoport-Self-Update gemacht?
Das kann ich natürlich auch nochmal probieren.
Das solltest du mal zuerst tun, weil...
Das habe ich bei der Installation gemacht, aber...
Wie lange ist die her?
Das ist ein Monat, anderthalb. Okay, Self-Update ohne...
Also ich wollte nicht sagen, dass das perfekt funktioniert. Das ist definitiv eine Hilfe. Die Alternative ist, dass du es halt selber nimmst. Na gut, das mag aber auch an dem Paket liegen.
Das mag an dem Paket liegen, das wird viele Gründe haben, aber dieses Abget unter Ubuntu oder unter Debian, das ist so ein allgemeingültiges...
Das liegt aber auch da.
Da sind viele Leute, die kümmern sich drum, da gibt es viele Quellen.
Ja, natürlich, weil wenn das nicht funktionieren würde, würde das ganze OS nicht funktionieren. Hier ist das ja sozusagen nur so ein kleines Add-on. Das ist eine relativ kleine Gemeinde. Und vielleicht sollte man nochmal kurz erklären, wie da die Dynamik funktioniert. Also jeder Port hat einen Maintainer. Du kannst jederzeit Maintainer werden. Wenn man so halbwegs einen Plan hat, wie man Unix Software übersetzt, dann muss man eigentlich nur rauskriegen, was da sozusagen gemacht werden muss. Und dann kann man diese ganzen Anweisungen selber schreiben. Das ist übrigens eine der schönen Sachen bei MacPorts. Dieses Portfile ist echt eine der leserlicheren Varianten. Fink, dieses andere Projekt, was es gibt, das basiert ja tatsächlich. Basiert das auf dem UpGate-Gramm, oder?
Das basiert auf D-Package, auf Deselect und auf UpGate, genau.
Ah ja, so. Und das ist halt ungemein kryptischer. MacPorts wiederum ist in Tickle geschrieben. Eine Designentscheidung, die ich jetzt auch nicht gerade besonders glorios finde, aber naja, so be it. Man kann dann halt so dafür im Portfile auch gleich Code reinschreiben. Das heißt, du kannst minimal Code in Tickle schreiben. So die grundsätzlichen Schleifen und irgendwie IF-Geschichten mögen dann ganz handy sein. Aber du hast halt in der Regel alles in einem Portfile. Das Portfile ist recht elegant gemacht. Da stecken auch jetzt die Leute dahinter, hier Jordan Hubbard vom FreeBSD-Projekt, der halt auch die Ports da gemacht hat. Und eben gegenüber dem Portsystem von FreeBSD zahlreiche Verbesserungen eingeführt hat. Also zum Beispiel diese Staging-Geschichte mit dem Activation hatte ich ja schon beschrieben. Und die Portfiles sind einfach viel leseilicher. Das sind so ein paar Sachen, die sie da hübscher gemacht haben als bei FreeBSD Ports. Und du machst da halt nicht Make, sondern du hast halt so ein richtig schönes Tool, dieses Port-Tool, was eben auch noch, kannst auch sagen, Port installt. Dann sagt der, was alles installiert ist. Port irgendwie Self-Update. Dann macht er sich halt selbst. Also sowohl die Software wird neu installiert, als auch die Ports werden alle gemacht. Und noch zahlreiche andere Sachen, wie du das machen kannst. Aber es gibt Probleme.
Es gibt leider relativ viele Probleme. Ich würde es schön finden, wenn Apple sich um dieses Problem mal annimmt.
Das wird diskutiert, weil tatsächlich sind die meisten Leute, die bei MacPorts-Projekten arbeiten, Apple-Mitarbeit. Also der John Hubbard ist ja von Apple schon vor x Jahren gekauft worden. Von VBSD-Projekt weg zu Darwin. Und auch 4, 5, 6 andere, die da arbeiten, sind einfach, ich würde sagen es ist halb der Hälfte. Ich habe jetzt schon eine Weile das Projekt nicht mehr so intensiv verfolgt. Ich habe mir eine Weile selber Ports gemacht, deswegen war ich da immer im Chat und habe Meldingsliste und so weiter geguckt. Aber tatsächlich ist es so, das Ding ist nur, um die Ports wirklich schlagkräftig zu machen und um sie vor allem auf diesen selben Level zu heben, wie das bei Debian der Fall ist. Bei Debian sind ja diese Ports quasi Teil des OS.
Die sind elementar wichtig.
Und bei Mac OS X ist dem nicht so, sondern bei Mac OS X hast du halt nach wie vor PKG, den Installer, das ist eigentlich das primäre System und du hast diese Receipt-Files in slash libraries slash receipts, nicht wahr? Da sind sozusagen diese Rezepte, wollte ich gerade sagen, diese Quittung, wo drin steht, was wurde jetzt irgendwie installiert, was gehört dazu?
Werden die für irgendwas genutzt eigentlich?
Gute Frage. Deinstaller gab es ja früher mal bei Next, haben sie mit Mac OS X weggelassen. Kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass sie das ewig so weitermachen wollen, aber bisher gab es so recht keine Antwort. Ich weiß, dass es dann im Ports-Projekt längere Diskussionen gibt, schon seit Jahren, wie man das eben machen kann. Dass man erstens Ports, also Command-Line-Kram und das, was vom OS installiert wird, so zusammenbringt, dass sozusagen die Features von dem Standard-Installer, den Features von diesem Portsystem entsprechen, sodass man eben auch einfach etwas hinzu installieren kann. Jetzt ist es so, wenn ich ein Tool installiere, was Perl brauche. Irgend so ein in Perl geschriebenes, dasselbe mit Python. Und ich installiere als Sudo-Port mein Perl-Tool. So, zack, return. Was macht er als erstes? Warum? Weil bei den Ports liegt halt alles in slash opt slash local. Und ist damit komplett separat von dem Rest. Das ist auch ganz sinnvoll, weil wenn dir dieser ganze Kack irgendwie um die Ohren fliegt, dann machst du einfach rr-f slash opt einfach weg. Genau. Es gibt ein paar Ausnahmen, so renitente Tools, die unbedingt in user local und so weiter installiert sind. Aber in der Regel ist das nicht so. Also x11 zum Beispiel ist so ein Problem, das will nicht woanders sein, als wo es schon immer war. Funktioniert halt einfach alte, rottige... Scheiße. Aber grundsätzlich ist eigentlich alles in slash opt und du kannst das halt entfernen und weg ist es. Das heißt auch dein selbst übersetztes Perl und so weiter hat natürlich auch Vorteile, kannst auch neue Versionen installieren, aber du hast natürlich effektiv zwei Pearls parallel, weil dein OS hat ja schon einen Perl, hat schon einen Python, hat schon einen Ruby, hat alles da und eigentlich will man das nicht. Eigentlich will man das, was schon da ist. Bloß das geht halt nur, wenn das OS X, so wie es von der Installations-CD kommt, Ports-kompatible Informationen hinterlässt mit Dependencies in diesem ganzen Pipapo und das auf ein Ding macht. Und bisher, meiner Meinung nach, sah Apple einfach nicht genug Grund, nicht genug Bedarf, sich die Mühe zu machen, jetzt für diese Command Line Welt ihr Konzept, was anderen Anforderungen entspricht, das zu machen.
Zum Beispiel, was mir immer wieder auffällt, was bei diesen ganzen Port-Verfahren auch immer eine wunderbare Sache ist, muss man ja mal sagen, ist, ein System zu aktualisieren. Unter einem Debian oder unter einem Ubuntu ist das Up minus Get Update erstmal und dann Upgrade und schon hat man, sagt er, ich muss 500 Megabyte nachladen, komme in einer halben Stunde wieder und dann drückt man Ja und dann hat man eine halbe Stunde später ein komplett aktualisiertes System.
Ja wieso, bei Mac OS 10 sage ich Software Update und er sagt, es gibt fünf Updates und zack, return, du musst jetzt einfach regruten und fertig ist das.
Ja, von Apple die Updates, aber davon ist noch lange nicht mein BB-Edit aktualisiert oder mein Firefox oder weiß ja was.
Aktualisieren sich selber.
Also da würde ich schön finden, wenn es da auch irgendwo eine zentrale Verwaltung dafür gäbe, die sich Apple ein bisschen kümmert, also die müssten das initiieren, dass die Software dann auch installiert wird.
Das sah ja so ein bisschen so aus mit dem 10.5 Installer, ich weiß gar nicht mehr welche Änderungen danach aus, aber dass auch Fremdtools mit da rein können, aber ich glaube, das ist nicht im Interesse von Apple.
Das ist immer wieder eine Diskussion, aber das ist auch so ein Haftungsproblem.
Vor allem auch eine Optik, die wollen den Installer oder ihr Updater tool halt sauber halten, das soll nur Apple Zeug drin sein. Ich würde das auch nicht wollen. Ich würde das auch getrennt halten.
Ich hätte auch nichts dagegen, wenn alles über einen Update-Prozess läuft. Vor allem, weil du ja automatisch so Signierungen und so weiter dann alles mit drin hast und es natürlich auch eine gewisse Sicherheit bietet, weil dann eben auch nur Updates durchkommen. Ich meine, im Prinzip macht Apple das jetzt mit dem iPhone. Der App Store tut genau das und ich schätze mal, das könnte dann auch Rückwirkungen haben auf die Mac-Plattform. In guten und in schlechter Hinsicht haben wir ja auch schon mal drüber gesprochen hier, so mit Signieren und Tralala und von daher, keine Ahnung. Also ich hätte es auch gern, Tatsache ist, es ist nicht so, können wir nicht ändern und für die Ports heißt das eben auch nach wie vor, dass sie eben so Second Class Citizen sind. Sie liegen einfach darunter und müssen alles separat machen und sie können nicht auf den Standard-Live alles machen. Vorteil ist aber auch, du kannst es dir auch nicht verhunzen und das finde ich auch ehrlich gesagt durchaus ein Feature. Das ist auch nicht so ein großes Problem. Mein Gott, dann hast du halt dein beklopptes Pearl und sonst was nochmal doppelt.
Also wie gesagt, was mich daran ein bisschen stört jetzt gegenüber so diesen, dass es funktioniert leider nicht so gut wie auf anderen Betriebssystemen. Die Gründe dafür liegen auf der Hand, gar keine Frage, aber die Praxis ist, es funktioniert ganz konkret nicht.
Ja gut, wenn ich jetzt mal gucke, was ich hier eigentlich wirklich benutze, ich gucke gerade mal hier, Port installed, was habe ich denn eigentlich drauf? Also wenn ich so einen neuen Rechner mache, mein Rechner macht zumindest gerade einen Backup. Was habe ich denn installiert? Also ich habe hier installiert folgende Ports, Airport, das ist so ein Tool, was einem unter anderem sagen kann, Jetzt wird es aber doppelt und dreideutig. Wieso? Ja, es gibt einen Command Line Tool, das heißt Airport und das hilft einem. Weißt du noch, damals hat Apple für Passwörter ja schon immer so einen Hash String verwendet, aber der Algorithmus war so nie bekannt und war anders als bei anderen. Die anderen haben immer nur Namen zu ASCII gemacht und Apple hat halt schon immer einen Hash von dem String gemacht. Dieser Algorithmus ist in diesem Tool und wenn ich solche Probleme noch habe, brauche ich dieses Tool. Dann habe ich hier B7-2, Expat, das sind alles so Dependencies.
B7-2, aber das ist doch ein System dabei.
Ja, das ist halt was ich sagte. Da gibt es eine Dependency auf B7-2.
Da kann ich nur empfehlen, es gibt einen PBZip2, parallel BZip, der nutzt beide CPUs gleichzeitig. Gerade für Leute, die MacPro haben mit 8 Cores. Ja, parallel BZip, der rockt richtig los.
Gucken wir mal, der ist zum Beispiel in den Ports.
Das gleiche gibt es auch für GZip, das heißt dann PIGZ, P-E-G-Z. Der kann das auch. Das geht ab wie Schmitzkatze dann. Wenn man richtig große Logfiles wegpacken muss, das dauert ja schon noch mal so ein bisschen.
PBZip2. Gucken wir mal, jetzt war ich hier, Sudo Port installiert, PBZip2, sagt er Fetching, holt sich das Ding von Compression.ca, Verifying CheckZoom, Extracting, Configuring, Building, Staging into Death Route, das heißt, er macht jetzt überhaupt erst mal dasselbe Layout der Files, wie es später installiert werden soll. Dann wird es installiert und dann wird es Activated und Cleaning, das heißt, die ganzen Files, die beim Compilation angefallen sind, die werden weggeschmissen. Und jetzt habe ich PBZip2 installiert. Ich meine, einfacher geht es ja wohl nicht.
Wie heißt die Auspackvariante dazu dann?
Nee, das merkt das Ding selbst.
PBZip-Tralala, wahrscheinlich.
Das merkt er, wenn er die Endung sieht, dann packt er einfach aus, glaube ich.
Na gut, also ich kann dir mal sagen, welche Ports ich eigentlich immer installiere, wenn ich einen neuen Rechner habe oder einen neuen Setup habe. Ich installiere mir GNU-PG, ich installiere mir MTR, weil das brauche ich einfach. MTR ist so ein Trace Route, was aber anders funktioniert als Trace Route, was besser ist und wo du einfach sehr viel schöner sehen kannst, wie viele Dropouts du hast. Also Trace Route macht ja immer nur zum ersten, zum zweiten, zum dritten, zum vierten und so weiter.
Heißt My Trace Route.
Und MTR macht halt alle parallel und du siehst halt sehr viel besser, wo du Packet Lots haben. Genau und das will ich halt immer haben und alles, was ich mache, ist halt so, du Port Install. Also für die Leute, die jetzt schon irgendwie Port Install eingegeben haben und festgestellt haben, dass sie das Port Tool nicht haben, man muss natürlich erstmal die MacPorts installieren. Also macports.org.
Wo ist dann die Adresse davon, wo man das kriegt für die, für unsere Hörer? Okay.
Hab ich gesagt. So, was hab ich noch? Nmap installiere ich mir halt immer.
Hacke, Hacker, las sie an ihr wischen.
Ich seh grad, ich hab hier, ah ja, und Weget. Das sind eigentlich immer so meine Standards.
MTR hab ich auch, Weget auch.
Weget nutzt sich mit einem Hacker.
Ich hab normalerweise auch noch mehr. Ich hab ja irgendwie nicht alles.
Ich hab dann noch nen Squid drauf. Wenn ich bei meiner Oma bin, geh ich nämlich über Analog Modem ins Internet. Und dann brauch ich nen Squid, der mir alles ein bisschen flotter macht.
Bei Oma ist sozusagen wie bei Oma.
Bei Oma ist es außerhalb vom Aufland, nicht ganz so schlimm. Aber schon nicht mehr im Dorf, sondern davor auf der Straße zum Dorf.
Also zerstörst du deinen eigenen Webcache?
Ich hab da meinen UFO dabei. Mein UFO hat ja einen Modem mit drin. Dann schließe ich meinen UFO in der Telefondose an. Oma merkt nichts, weil es ja per Funk dann connectet. Und dann sitze ich halt da und mach so. Und ja, ihr Telefon ist besetzt, weil sie hat ja kein ISD. Aber das war ich nur abends.
Tja, sowas. Und vor allem, wenn irgendeiner sagt, da gibt es auch das Tool hier, wie du das gemacht hast. Neulich hab ich zum Beispiel dieses P7-Zip.
Kurze Frage, womit ruf ich denn das auf, dieses MTR? MTR will er bei mir nicht.
Na, wenn du so einen Pfad vielleicht nicht angegeben hast.
Wo ist es denn installiert? Du musst natürlich in deinem Punkt binnen.
Dann muss ein Sino davor. Wahrscheinlich, oder?
Voller Hacker-Kanal hier auf einmal, wa? Ist nicht mehr so buddy-clicky und irgendwie für dumme User. Jetzt geht es richtig auf die Kommando-Zahler, Jungs.
Jetzt kommen hier die Top-Inside-Informationen. Übrigens muss ich jetzt nochmal dazusagen, wenn wir gerade dabei sind. Die meisten Leute denken ja, dass Sbin steht für Super-User-Binary. Das stimmt aber gar nicht, weil es heißt, eigentlich von ganz früher kommt es von Static Binaries, die nämlich nicht mehr irgendwie extern gelingt sind, sondern immer gehen, falls man seinen Slash-User noch nicht gemountet hat oder irgendwie so. Und SU heißt nämlich auch gar nicht Super-User, das ist nämlich schon voll falsch, aber es kommt nämlich von Substitut-User. Es geht ja auch für andere User.
Wow, du bist ja echt hip. Jetzt kannst du mir wahrscheinlich sogar noch sagen, was USR heißt.
Das hätte ich jetzt auch noch gekonnt.
Nein, USR steht nicht für User. Also jeder sagt natürlich User. Das heißt Unix System Resources.
Ach, logisch.
Jetzt, wo du es sagst, fällt es mir wieder ein, wie Schub von den Haaren.
Ja, das stimmt. Und auch irgendwie, ja, Bin und USR Bin ist halt auch so ähnlich. Es war die schnelle Platte und die langsame Platte in dem Rechner, wo sie mal Unix gehackt haben. Und die Tools, die sie häufiger aufgerufen haben, wie LS, die kamen immer aus Bin, aus der schnellen Platte und alles andere, was zu seltener war, das kam von USR Bin.
Genau, vor allem was auch beim Booten schon gebraucht wurde, wo halt die andere Platte eventuell noch nicht gemountet war, musste halt nach Bin.
Wie auch immer. Also ich finde diese Ports, ja, so ist das, das ist gewachsen. Von daher, ich meine, es gibt auch so viele Leute, die sind immer so, ah ja, Unix und so weiter, das ist überhaupt das Beste. Ich meine, Unix ist wirklich ein alter Lappen und es ist ausgetragen. Es ist einfach nur deshalb cool, weil es einfach von Anfang an bis heute durchgehalten hat auf eigentlich nahezu außer Microsoft, alle darauf basieren mittlerweile und es ist halt einfach, wenn man es kennt und wenn man es halbwegs gelernt hat es zu lieben und zu benutzen, dann ist alles super. Aber elegant ist es an vielen Stellen echt nicht. Also gerade die Unix-Kommandos ist eigentlich ein Stück Dreck. Das ist alles so inkonsistent und so schlimm.
Aber eigentlich ist das schon ganz schön cool.
Ja, aber dann ist es halt auch wieder ganz cool. Das stimmt schon. Anyway, jetzt hatte ich gerade dieses P7 Zip erwähnt. Und was sagtest du da gerade?
Wofür braucht man das eigentlich nicht, wenn man nicht gerade...
Gerade der beste Komprimierer, den es so gibt. Also es gibt immer noch welche, sind noch so ein Stück besser für Spezialfälle, aber dieser P7 Zip, der rockt noch mal eine Menge mehr als der BZip 2, der eigentlich sonst schon als bessere Alternative für den GZip.
Da bin ich nämlich erst vor kurzem drauf gestoßen. Irgendjemand hat mir so eine Chaos-Radio mitgestattet und meinte, so ein P7 Zip ist ja bestimmt kein Problem für dich. Und ich so, was, wie, was ist denn das? Ich dachte schon, das wäre irgendwie so was wie die Haare oder so.
Nee, das ist eigentlich richtig cooler Scheiß. Das Problem ist bloß, dass die sich wohl da nicht so richtig einig sind und der dieses P7 ist halt erstmal der Algorithmus an sich, dann kommt es halt noch drauf an, wie das Zeug eingepackt ist, sozusagen der Container und die streiten sich halt gerade wieder mal beim Container-Format und beim Windows ist es irgendwie anders als auf der Command Line und dann tricksen sie alle rum und deswegen sieht man ja, hat er sich wieder mal nicht so richtig durchgesetzt, wo es halt bei bzip oder bei pbzip irgendwie, da gibt es halt nur einen und der tut halt und das rockt. Aber dieser P7 der ist echt nochmal richtiges Ding ins Besser.
Aber ich glaube, das wunderbare Programm Anarchiver, was so ein Programm ist, das diese ganzen Apple-Tools ersetzt, genauso aussieht wie die Apple-Tools, aber ist jetzt GUI oder Command Line?
Das grüne Ding, was hier mal hochpoppt oder was? Das ist doch von Apple, oder?
Genau, da gibt es den Anarchiver, das ist eine Alternative dazu und das kann dann glaube ich auch dieses B7 Zip auspacken. Aber Ach so, verstehe. Anarchiver, das suche ich mal die URL raus.
Also ein guter Entpacker, der mal universell ist, das finde ich ja mal ganz cool, weil ich bin irgendwie immer noch, kann der auch Stuff-It? Kann ich da nicht meinen Stuff-It-Expander wegschmeißen?
Ich muss jetzt mal die Mate öffnen, wir können jetzt mal anstoßen. Ich bin jetzt seit Jahren Stuff-It-Expander los und stolz drauf.
Seit wie? Seit sechs Jahren?
Seit Jahren ist egal wie viel. Aber der Stuff-It-Expander muss sterben.
Das wäre der Titel für diese Folge, wenn wir sowas machen würden.
Ach komm, bitte als Unterzeichen. Das ist zu gut, um es sein zu lassen.
Untertitel haben wir schon gar nicht.
Was?
So ist es. Wir haben ja nicht mal einen Jingle, Mann.
Ja, aber dann können wir wenigstens hier Unterzeichen drunter packen.
Wir sind so ein Toast- und Marmelade-Podcast hier.
Toast und Marmelade?
Hier gibt es nicht irgendwie Sachen.
Habt ihr eigentlich gehört, dass Mac gerade voll in ist?
Was?
Überhaupt nicht.
Weil die CT-Sondenausgabe haben wir glaube ich vor zwei Wochen auch berichtet. Habe ich gerade ganz heiß reinbekommen, dass die nachdrücken müssen, weil die waren weg wie die warmen Semmeln. Die mussten ihre Werbung einstellen, weil sie keine mehr hatten. Und jetzt drucken sie fett nach. Und das heißt, wenn ihr unsere Sendung hört, sind die wieder frisch am Start.
Das heißt, bei Heise sitzen sie jetzt und sagen...
Mit Marketing hat gerade Herzflaschen.
Sie haben festgestellt, dass irgendwie, was? Die Leute wollen nicht Linux?
Wir müssen mehr Mac-Zeug-Dings machen.
Ich sagte ja Hannover.
Haben wir nicht so einen Grafiker, der ja auch ein Mac hat?
Oh Mann.
Wie soll das Heise in Hannover sein? Verstehe. Hab ich gerade noch so reingekriegt. So, jetzt hatten wir noch...
Ich war mal... Ich bin ja aus Hannover.
Ich kenne Heise noch so ein bisschen aus frühen Zeiten.
Irgendwie nicht alles, nur so ein paar Redaktionen. Zum Beispiel die Input 64.
Aber das waren noch Zeiten, oder? Wo die CT alle vier Wochen rauskam und dann war die so fett, dass sie meinten, das geht nicht mehr, wir müssen jetzt alle zwei Wochen rausbringen. Und das ist auch schon wieder ewig her, oder?
Da hab ich sogar noch mitgelesen schon. Wieso?
Wie häufig kommt sie denn jetzt raus?
Ja, aber früher immer alle vier Wochen. Ja, aber ist schon wieder ewig her.
Das könnte fast noch letztes Jahr 1000 gewesen sein.
2000 oder so? 2001? Keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß nicht. Ich blätter immer mal wieder so in der CT im Laden. Und es ist alles immer nur Windows. Windows, wie reparier ich mein Windows? Mein Windows ist kaputt. Wie mach ich mein Windows schneller?
Ach, hin und wieder sind doch mal ein paar nette Artikel dabei.
Was denn?
Ich hab zum Beispiel gestern hat mich jemand gefragt, wie man mit Python auf dem Nokia, auf Symbian S60-Telefon was macht. Da konnte ich auf einen alten CT-Artikel verweisen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das wirklich das ist, was ich in der Computerzeitschrift lesen will.
Ach doch, ich finde, was ist eigentlich die Aufgabe von so Printmagazinen im 21. Jahrhundert, die unglaublich schnell sind und weiß ja tausend was? Ich glaube, was die CT...
Programmlistings zum abtippen.
Und alternativ auf das Kette noch zu, kann man sich zuschicken lassen. Nein, aber so dieses, sich einem Thema wirklich gut annehmen, richtig tief reingehen, nicht nur hier einen Link zu einer Download-Seite anbieten und da, sondern so einen langen Artikel darüber machen, das war eigentlich immer so eine Stärke von der CT. Und manchmal kriegen sie das bis heute noch hin, insofern. Also CT muss nicht sterben.
Das ist auch ein bisschen einfacher, um gegen Marktführer zu hauen. Da würde ich jetzt auch gar nicht einstimmen. Letzten Endes sind sie immer noch viel besser als alle anderen. Das muss man ihnen wirklich lassen. Und sie sind auch im Online-Bereich einfach unersetzlich.
Und der Mac-Zeitschriftenbereich ist dann auch relativ erwärmlich.
Also wenn sie sich das bringen, wenn sie sich jetzt wirklich alles nachdrucken, ich kann dir ja sagen, da wird es eine Diskussion geben, ob sie jetzt endlich ihre iX einstampfen und vielleicht mal ein Macintosh-Magazin rausbringen. Das werden bold moved.
Die iX können sie ja lassen, wo ist denn die einstampfen?
Die iX finde ich ein bisschen überflüssig. Multitasking, Multiuser-Magazin.
Bitte dich.
Die machen aber auch immer eine Menge Mac-Shit.
Mittlerweile, ja.
Ja doch, iPhone-Programmierung, OS X Server. Vielleicht sollte ich mal durch die iX Blätter, nicht immer durch die CT.
Vielleicht ist es das ja einfach. Das Endanwendermagazin ist die CT für den Microsoft-Benutzer. Frontend und Backend. Und dann gibt es das Profi-Magazin für Mac.
Es versteht sich als Profi-Magazin, dieses iX, aber ich weiß nicht, ich fand es einfach eine Zeit lang einfach herrenlos.
Also wenn sie da irgendwie ihren 128. Bladeserver getestet haben, das hat mich natürlich auch nicht die Bohne interessiert, aber auch da wiederum, manche...
Es verkauft sich auch mehr in den Enterprise-Markt rein, das muss man natürlich auch so sehen.
Wir werden ja sehen, was da demnächst so bei den Jungs aus der Eiser-Redaktion was dazu kommt.
Aber das ist natürlich schick, dass sich das gut verkauft. Ich weiß nicht, hast du das gekauft? Hat irgendjemand von uns die STT-Sondermagazin?
Ich hab's nicht gekauft. Ich glaub, ich hätt's gekauft, wenn's mir ins Auge gesprungen wäre.
Das waren ja alle wegverkauft, da kommt einem nichts ins Auge gestellt.
Sind die noch beim Drucken oder sind die jetzt schon fertig?
Nee, es soll jetzt ab morgen wieder losgehen.
Wenn ich jetzt diesen Anarchiver installiere, haut der mir dann den anderen weg oder was?
Nee, nee, du musst noch bei einem ZIP-Archiv explizit sagen.
Mini-Morphor mit den Bonn-Artscheif-Hältern.
Das ist ein ganz braves kleines Programm, was einfach nur tut, was es soll.
Und das plackt sich so ein und dann ist es irgendwie...
Das plackt sich nicht ein. Nee, man muss dann noch bei ZIP-Archiven, muss man dann noch Apfel-E sagen. Und dann muss man sagen, mach ab sofort meine...
Wo liegt denn das Original? Das Original liegt in Slash-System.
Das liegt irgendwo ganz tief.
Stuff-It.
Genau, das kann auch Stuff-It.
Ha! Cool, dann kann ich Stuff-It-Expander löschen.
Ja, endlich, gleich noch mal einen anschauen.
Stuff-It-Expander... Stuff...
Du machst jetzt wirklich die rituelle Löschung? Stuff-It-Expander war so unglaublich langweilig. Langsam auch.
Ich hasse dieses Programm.
Ja, und man braucht das vor allem früher immer. Und inzwischen braucht man es nicht mehr.
Früher war es doch super.
Stoß an, die rituelle Löschung, Reinwaschung des Stuff-It-Expander.
Dein Rechner schwebt auch plötzlich so ein bisschen.
Er ist leichter geworden.
Er ist leichter geworden. Stunde neun Minuten, wir kommen voran. Anarchalver, Punkt ab. Toll, wieder so ein Tool. Achso, übrigens, du hast ja vorhin gebettelt nach so einem ich möchte gerne alles zentral updaten. Da gibt es ja tatsächlich dieses Tool ab. Fresh, Punkt ab. Ich kann dir das leider nur eingeschränkt empfehlen, weil es nicht sehr super zuverlässig alles so aktualisiert. Viele Sachen findet es einfach nicht, die aktuellen Versionen, und zeigt einem wirklich bekloppte Versionen an, die es gar nicht gibt und so. Aber im Großen und Ganzen ist es schon mal eine Hilfe dabei, überhaupt festzustellen, was neu ist. Und es aktualisiert sich selbst immer ganz nett. Immerhin.
Uneingeschränkt empfehlen kann ich auch einige andere Applikationen zum aktualisieren. Ich würde gerne eingeschränkt empfehlen. Ich würde gerne eins uneingeschränkt empfehlen können. Ach so, würdest du gerne. Würde ich gerne, kann ich aber nicht, weil es gibt leider nichts wirklich Gutes.
Du meinst jetzt ein Updater-Tool oder generelles Software?
Generelles Software kann man bestimmt einiges empfehlen.
Ja, wir sollten mal über unsere Lieblingssoftware reden.
Das wäre noch ein schönes Thema, das können wir vielleicht ein andermal machen. Müssen wir nicht jetzt machen, aber erwähnen kann man es trotzdem mal. Software, die man immer wieder aktualisiert, obwohl man sie eigentlich nie benutzt. Also ich benutze zum Beispiel, ich habe mir irgendwann mal das Programm Awaken gekauft. Das ist so ein kleiner Weg. Also ich habe es nicht gekauft, sondern es war in unserem McHeist-Bundle dabei. Und dieses wunderbare kleine Programm schafft es, es ist ein kleiner Wecker im Wesentlichen, den ich niemals benutzen würde. Ich hatte einen Wecker. Und der schafft es nicht, mir die korrekte Zeit anzuzeigen. Der zeigt nämlich nie die Stunde an, sondern immer nur die Minute. Das heißt, jedes Mal, wenn eine neue Version von dem Programm rauskommt, aktualisiere ich es, nur um zu sehen, ob sie es diesmal vielleicht geschafft haben, dass jetzt auch die Stunde angezeigt wird. Das ist schon ein Problem.
Ein Wecker, der nicht in der Lage ist, die Zeit anzuzeigen?
Ein Wecker, der nicht in der Lage ist, die Zeit anzuzeigen.
Dafür hast du Geld bezahlt?
Dafür hab ich indirekt Geld bezahlt. Indirekt? Über dieses Bundle-Paket. Mac heißt. Mac heißt, genau. Da war das mit dabei. Neben Software, die ich tatsächlich haben wollte.
Das ist ja geil. Das ist ja wie mein Nokia-Telefon.
Ja, genau. Und du hast sogar noch richtig Geld dafür bezahlt, siehst du?
Nee, ich hab's geschenkt bekommen. Das hat die irgendwie am Geist. Ein Telefon, was an zwei unterschiedlichen Stellen zwei unterschiedliche Uhrzeiten anzeigt.
Was?
Ja, das macht mein Nokia. Das weiß ich nicht, wie sie das machen.
Das ist ja auch relativ groß, dass man nicht passt, dass du zwei Zeit so umdrehen.
Die Uhrzeit im Screensaver war definitiv eine andere als die auf dem Main-Screen. Die differierten um ein oder zwei Minuten. Du guckst mich an, ich hab genau so geguckt.
Ich bin wirklich glatt.
Ja, und vor allem irgendwie das Ganze, während ich meine schwangere Freundin ins Krankenhaus gefahren habe und versucht habe, irgendwie während des Fahrens noch irgendwie so die Zeit im Blick zu halten, dabei ist mir das aufgefallen und ich dachte, ich spinne.
Weiß sie das? Oder erfährt sie es jetzt in ihrem Podcast?
Es ging alles gut. Alles war super.
Dann stellen wir keine weiteren Fragen.
Ja, ja, ja. Vielleicht hier nochmal im Nachgang. Wir haben uns ja letztes Mal so schön über Microsoft gestritten. Das müssen wir jetzt nicht in aller Länge nachmachen, aber seitdem ist ja nochmal einiges passiert. Microsoft will jetzt doch nicht Yahoo kaufen. Oder hat eingesehen, dass sie es nicht gekauft bekommen. Mir ist nicht so ganz klar, was das heißt.
Der Bäume hat gesagt, sie sind nicht interessiert und danach hat Yahoo gesagt, dann lass uns doch nochmal hinsetzen, oder?
Ja, so, was denn? Und überhaupt? Das war sie gar nicht gemeint. Meine Shareholder bringen mich um. Ich wollte doch nur hoch pokern. Aber ich glaube, Microsoft, das haben die auch so ein bisschen durcherkennen lassen, dass ihre eigenen Shareholder das nicht so geil gefunden hätten, weil sie einfach der Meinung waren, wie ich übrigens auch, dass das eine Vollkatastrophe gewesen wäre für Microsoft, weil die beiden Firmen einfach nicht zusammengehen.
Da kann man bestimmt bei Fake Steve Jobs auch prima wieder schön drüber nachlesen und sich ein Ablachen.
Da kann man bei Fake Steve Jobs einiges drüber nachlesen.
Ich fand den allerersten Artikel bei Fake Steve Jobs zu dem Thema fand ich eigentlich am geilsten, wo diese Bildchen gezeigt wurden mit Bäumer und dem Young und naja, so ein bisschen nicht ganz so jugendfrei, aber sehr unterhaltsam auf jeden Fall. Naja, ich weiß nicht, ob die noch zusammengehen. Ich glaub's nicht, weil letzten Endes hat er Ihnen irgendwie erzählt, wenn ihr versucht uns Hostile, Takeover-mäßig feindliche Übernahme zu machen, dann machen wir euch fertig, weil wir haben hier irgendwie einen Deal mit Google und wenn ihr uns dann kauft, dann kauft ihr irgendwie einen Deal mit Google, der wird euch nicht gefallen. So, die Nummer haben die Gefahren.
Aber wenn's das jetzt wirklich war, dann bin ich baff enttäuscht von Steve Baumer, ohne Scheiß. Den hatte ich für, also ich hoffe mal, dass der noch irgendwas in der Hinterheit hat. Also einfach nur, damit jetzt mein Weltbild komplett zusammenkommt.
Ich wundere mich, warum er nicht seine Arme gehoben hat und einfach sein schweißdurchtränktes Hemd eingesetzt hat.
Und laut Yahu Yahu Yahu geschrien hat.
Ja, und den jagen einfach zu benebeln. Und dann irgendwie in so ein...
Vielleicht hat er ein frisches Hemd angehabt.
Aber die geilste Meldung ist doch hier wirklich, auf PC World war das, dass Microsoft jetzt ein neues Betriebssystem für portable, mobile Computer bietet. Cheap Laptops.
Unglaublich, wie heißt denn das? Das klingt nach Innovation.
Das ist nur 6,5 Jahre alt und sie werden es dann auch noch beschneiden in seinen Features. Wie kann man auf sowas nur kommen? Und das geile ist, und das ist ja auch eine der Sachen, über die wir geredet haben, Sie haben kein OS für kleine Computer. Während Apple die latest und greatest Mac OS X auf dem Telefon installiert bekommt, sind sie noch nicht mal in Lager auf solchen billig kleinen Ultra-Light-PCs, ULPCs, hier Vista zu installieren. Das geht einfach nicht, weil das einfach ein riesen Bloat ist, der nur auf Desktops funktioniert. Weil sie gedacht haben, der Desktop-Markt, das geht immer so weiter. Sie haben einfach nicht gesehen, dass der Trend zu mobil geht und deswegen ist ihre mobile Dominanz einfach...
Also kurzfristig machen die wahrscheinlich nochmal richtig dick Kohle für ein Produkt, das sie ja schon ewig haben. Aber langfristig geht denn ja was weg.
Also ich glaube, sie wollen nur verhindern, dass diese Hersteller Linux nehmen, weil das ist nämlich echt gewohnt.
In diesem kleinen Bereich, die nehmen alle Linux oder dann haben sie alternativen Windows und Linux drauf.
Hier den EPC.
Und dann ist die Linux-Version immer besser oder immer deutlich günstiger und wirklich deutlich günstiger und schließt in allen Tests, zu sagen, yeah, Linux ist super.
Nur Negro Ponte möchte natürlich sein One Laptop per Child-Projekt gerne auf Windows umstellen. Ja, er meinte, dass die XO-Computer alle wollen ja jetzt irgendwie Windows haben und ihm wäre sowieso nie um Linux gegangen, sondern um das Konzept an sich und wenn die Ziele auch mit Windows machbar sind, dann sollen sie auch da Windows drauf installieren. Hat Negro Ponte gesagt, mittlerweile ist natürlich in der Open Source-Szene der große Arsch. Also in der freien Software-Szene der große Arsch. Richard Stolmen meinte auch gleich so, was soll das denn? Und ich hab ja hier gerade auf mein Richard Stolmen einen Blog-Eintrag geschrieben, wo er meinte, ich hab aber gerade auf ein XO umgesattelt und der Grund war, dass es der einzige PC ist, der auch noch mit einem freien BIOS kommt. So und deswegen hätte er das gemacht. Tatsächlich wäre allerdings noch eine Sache nicht frei auf dem XO, der WLAN-Triver. Weißt du, was er dann gemacht hat? Richard Stolmen hat den Driver gelöscht. Er meinte, also jetzt habe ich zwar keinen WLAN mehr, aber dafür ist er frei.
Aber Internet hat er gar nicht mehr, oder?
Man kann da Internet reinstecken.
Da kann man Internet reinstecken.
Aber wer braucht WLAN?
Wer braucht schon Internet?
Wer braucht WLAN? Richard Stolmen ist das Internet, wahrscheinlich. Er braucht im Falle keinen WLAN. Das führt alles zu weit. Auf jeden Fall Microsoft. Ich sagte ja, die Jungs sind doomed. Du kannst mir erzählen, was du willst. Und vor allem ihre Hilflosigkeit zeigt sich doch jetzt auch. Habt ihr das mitbekommen mit dem MSN? Sie blocken im Chat YouTube-Links. Was? Ja. Wenn Leute mit Cut und Paste anderen Leuten über MSN einen YouTube-Link machen, dann blocken sie den. Und wenn du eine Zahl änderst in der Domain, dann geht's. Also ein Buchstaben änderst, hinzufügst, was auch immer, also die Domain sozusagen nicht YouTube ist, dann geht's durch.
Nein, das ist ein April-Scherz, oder?
Nein.
Wir legen uns jetzt beide auf der Stelle in MSN-Ankaufs.
Es war auf Heise, es ist wahr. Das ist ja Zensur.
Kann man dagegen nicht vorgehen?
Was weiß ich, was sie in ihrem Fine-Print stehen haben, aber die werden sich sicherlich irgendwas einfallen lassen.
Ich suche jetzt mal bei Heise hier YouTube, MSN, bla bla bla.
Wo ist es denn? Nee, war es auf Heise? Wo war denn das verdammt? Ich hab das... Ja, man muss ja die Quellen nennen. Du hast ja recht, ich immer mit meinem Das war da und da. Tralala. Was, jetzt kommt nichts? Ist das blöd? War ich denn in einer Gedankenblase?
War es vielleicht doch SEQ?
Nee, war MSN.
The Inquirer. Microsoft blockiert YouTube-Links.
Inquirer.
Blablabla, das ist aber auch alles. Die zahlreichen Nutzer berichten, es ist heute um 11.35 Uhr, ganz, ganz frisch. Die zahlreichen Nutzer berichten, kamen Nachrichten mit YouTube-Links bei MSN und Windows Live Messenger nicht mehr durch. Sollte stattdessen die Nutzung von MSN Video erwünscht sein, die Nachrichten kamen mit der Meldung zurück, der Link hätte den Empfänger nicht übermittelt werden können. Beta Daily berichtete darüber und sieht es im Zusammenhang mit dem Start von Microsoft Messenger TV. Das erinnert an Microsoft älteste und bewährtest Tradition, denn unlängst wurde mit Messenger TV in 20 Ländern ein Dienst, der blablabla.
Hier gibt es einen Blog-Eintrag dazu, und da steht drin, es sei mittlerweile wieder behoben. Erstes Update. Not surprisingly, YouTube things are working again. Update 2. The Windows Live Messenger Blog published a post admitting the problem, which they claim was entirely controlled by a third party and the process of blocking harmful URLs. Das heißt, sie sind der Meinung, dass irgendwie so ein Virenscanner, irgendwie so ein Extern, den sie genommen haben, das Ganze gemacht hat. Wer es glaubt, wird selig. So, so. Na wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall. Wir müssen uns nicht an solche Details festhalten, aber wir beenden das gleich mit dem Microsoft-Thema. Oder? Wir haben letztes Mal eigentlich schon alles gesagt. Ich bin nach wie vor der Meinung, die Jungs kriegen einfach keinen Fuß mehr auf die Erde. Und mir vollkommen egal, ob die im Enterprise-Markt immer noch stark sind, das lässt halt einfach alles nach. Das lässt halt einfach alles nach. Die lassen einfach nach.
Ja, aber der Wind kann sich auch wieder drehen. Das ist alles, was ich sagen möchte. Winde haben sich schon öffnet.
Dennis, was sagst du denn?
Ich bin Max Winde, ich drehe mich den ganzen Tag über...
Ich bin da.
Du windest dich. Dir ist das alles egal.
Ja, hab ja mit dem nix zu tun.
Ich hab übrigens mir eine Time Capsule gekauft. Ach.
Ach.
Aber wo Microsoft Produkte...
Ich hab mir eine Express gekauft. Eine neue.
Ja, hast du schon mal erzählt. Und ist toll?
Ich hab Spargel gegessen.
Nö, bisher nicht.
Nee?
Bessere Reichweite, auch gehst du näher an meinem Schlafzimmer dran. Aber ich kann jetzt endlich wieder Musik an meine Hand anschicken.
Also diese kleine Airport Extreme, die hier gerade in meiner Hand ist.
Brauchst du denn nicht mehr?
Nö, die verkauf ich jetzt.
Jetzt? Jetzt? Was willst du denn haben? Ich hab einen Zähler dabei.
Ich hab einen Express jetzt.
Tja, das wird teuer. Na, die kommt auf ebay. Die werd ich schon zu ordentlichen Marktpreisen verhökern. Die ist ja an sich völlig in Ordnung. Aber ich kann euch sagen, Time Machine mit dem Teil mit mehreren USB-Festplatten, das war meine Konfiguration, über andere kann ich keine Aussage treffen, ist nicht stabil. Schlimmer noch, das Ding musste ich jeden Tag einmal rebooten. Und zwar...
Und das nennst du mit, ist das ein eindeutig in Ordnung?
Ich bin halt ehrlich. Ich meine, wenn man es nicht dafür verwenden will, ist das Ding prima. Aber wenn man der Meinung ist, man könnte eben über dieses unsupported USB-Disk Time Machine-Dingsbums...
Das ist doch nicht unsupported.
Doch, das ist unsupported.
Ach so, unsupported, ja okay, aber es geht.
Es geht, aber es ist unsupported, du darfst dich bei Apple nicht beklagen. Und ich kann halt sagen, das ist nicht zuverlässig. Ich hatte einfach folgende Effekte, dass eben der File-Server abstürzt und auch das ganze Management abstürzt. Das heißt, du kannst das Ding nicht mal mehr aus der Ferne resetten, du musst richtig hingehen, den Strom entziehen und wieder hinzufügen. Und dann brütet der und dann geht es wieder eine Weile. Aber wenn das Ding unter Last ist, geht es einfach in die Knie. Und ich habe einfach Bedenken. Was kostet so ein Ding? Gute Frage. Ich frage mal in der Apple Store. Ich habe jetzt gerade 178 Euro, glaube ich.
Und was willst du jetzt dafür haben?
Was denkst du denn? Da können wir gleich mal hier nach der Sendung drüber reden, aber so einfach ist ja nicht. Ich kann es dir unterschreiben, wenn du möchtest.
Ich unterschreibe es mir. Ich bin der Star. Ich bin voll der Podcast-Star.
Das stimmt, ja ich weiß.
Ich bin ein Star, holt mich heraus.
Da hab ich gerade einen tollen neuen Comic. Kennt ihr schon Geek and Poke?
Ja, großartig oder? Der ist gar nicht neu. Aber der geht gerade durch die Twitteri an.
Ich weiß so, dass das ein 64er-Witz ist, weil da wurde nämlich mit Geek and Poke gearbeitet.
Ein 64er-Witz?
Ja, ein 64er-Computer. Der Kommando 64. Da gab es die Kommandos Geek and Poke. Geek, um irgendwie Werte aus dem Speicher zu lesen, und Poke, um sie reinzuschreiben. War es richtig?
Auf jeden Fall gab es auf Geek und Poke hier eine schöne Sache. Guck mal, das ist doch schön. Hi, I'm an Internet Celebrity. What's an Internet Celebrity? I'm the host of a famous podcast. Das bist du, Dennis. What's a podcast? It's an RSS feed with embedded... Und Person geht weg. What a strange person. I guess I need another year to enter the mainstream. Als er geht.
Du meinst, wir sind noch nicht im Mainstream?
Ja, du bist zwar eine Internet Celebrity, aber nobody cares a shit, Dennis.
Shit.
So sieht das nämlich aus. Nur weil du ein RSS-Feed hast. Wie auch immer, geekandpoke.typepad.com Supergeile Kommentare zurzeit. Wieder mal so ein Ding, was man auch schön per RSS abonnieren kann. Ich hab viel gelacht.
Ich hab schon gedacht, ich wär der Allerletzte, weil ich da jetzt erst drüber gestolpert bin. Aber wir followen die gleichen Leute bei Twitter. Kann das sein?
Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Das kannst du dir nicht vorstellen? Das kann ich mir auch nur schwer vorstellen.
Haben wir schon mal erklärt, was Twitter ist?
Wer nicht weiß, was Twitter ist, ist der Lieblingsverlorer.
Du bist ja nicht auf Twitter. Warum eigentlich nicht?
Ich weiß nicht, was es ist.
Du weißt nicht, was Twitter ist?
Ja, doch, es ist so ein Messenger-Ding, aber so Events-basierend.
Was?
Nee, nicht wirklich.
Was denn dann?
Ich fand einen schönen Erklärung.
Hat man das schon mal? Ich bin mir jetzt nicht sicher.
Das ist krass und déjà vu, oder?
Ich kann es dir gerne nochmal erklären. Wenn ich es letztes Mal schon erklärt habe, weiß ich nicht genau. Twitter hat mir nicht... Soll ich mal im Internet gucken? Twitter ist...
Die beste Erklärung bisher, die ich bisher gefunden habe, ist wie ein normaler Instant-Messenger ausmacht, dass man nicht weiß, an wen die Nachrichten gehen.
Also, huuuh, verstehe.
Also man hat seine Follower, also wenn du jetzt...
Was heißt man weiß nicht? Es geht an alle.
Es geht an alle, es geht an die Welt.
Es ist Public, es ist einfach ein Public Chat. Du liest allerdings nur das, was Leute schreiben, den du explizit folgst, wie das so schön heißt im Twitter-Jargon. Das heißt, man wird ein Follower... Es gibt nicht so was wie ein Online-Status und so weiter. Man ist nicht online, das ist offline. Und du siehst nicht, dass ich online bin oder offline bin. Aber? Zunächst einmal, wenn du einfach was schreibst, schreibst du es sozusagen global.
Was schreibt man denn da so?
Was auch immer. Ich bohre mir gerade in der Nase... Ich fass mir einen Puller, was auch immer. Kannst schreiben, was du willst. Es gibt so Leute, die müssen halt alles Mögliche über sich schreiben, dass sie jetzt gerade eine Currywurst essen und so weiter.
Und das wird dann auch so historymäßig nacheinander gepostet. Und dann gibt es halt diese Tools, die einem immer zum Beispiel reinpumpen, was man gerade in seinem iTunes hört, zum Beispiel.
Es gibt alle möglichen Gateway, aber das ist ja nochmal eine ganz andere Geschichte. Twitter an sich funktioniert erstmal so. Du hast einen globalen Chat, alle sind in einem Namensraum. Und du kannst jedem auch explizit ansprechen, indem du seinen Twitter-Namen mit einem Add davor mit in deine Nachricht reinschreibst. Dann sieht er das auf jeden Fall. Ansonsten sieht er es nur, wenn er dir explizit folgt.
Und alle anderen sehen es aber trotzdem.
Generell, sozusagen in deinem Chat taucht eben das auf, was die Leute schreiben, den du folgst. Umso mehr Leuten du folgst, umso mehr bekommst du vor die Nase. Warum ich? Also ich würde es nicht benutzen, wenn sie nicht dieses tolle Feature hätten mit der Java-Integration. Das heißt, wenn du Java benutzt, und das tust du ja, dann kannst du in dem User-Interface, in dem Web-Interface sagen, schick mir mal, hier ist mein Java-Account. Und dann kommt halt twitter.com und subscrib dich in Java. Und dann sagst du, ok, alles klar, hallo, darfst du irgendwie hier in meinen Roster reinkommen? Und dann kriegst du eben diese ganzen Updates, die du sonst nur im Web sehen würdest, kriegst du halt per Java. Und du kannst aber auch diesem twitter.com einfach was schreiben, zack, return, und dann ist das dein Tweet.
Twitter ist eigentlich web-based?
Ja, Twitter ist eigentlich web-based, aber es ist an sich eigentlich per Pull, um jetzt nochmal auf das Thema zurückzukommen.
Jede Nachricht, mein letzter Hinweis, jede Nachricht, die du schreibst, ist wie geblockt. Das heißt, die hat einen Permalink mit einer URL und du kannst da irgendwie drauf hinklinken. Von daher ist es ein bisschen Microblogging und es ist ein bisschen Chatting. Aber es ist halt alles in einem Chatraum sozusagen und du hast so eine selektive Geschichte, so wie ignore im Chat, bloß andersrum. Du sagst halt explizit, wem du folgst und daraus generiert sich dein persönlicher Chat. Nee, hatten wir nicht.
Das macht großartig viel Spaß, weil man hat eine kleine Welt, in der man wirklich nur die Leute, nur Nachrichten von Leuten bekommt, die man auch bis zu einem gewissen Grad mag.
Und man kriegt echt sehr aktuell Sachen. Also die Dinger sind mittlerweile zuerst auf Twitter und danach in den Blogs.
Das geht sagenhaft schnell.
Das geht so rasant, ist echt, echt, echt fix.
Klar, aber im Blog muss man jede was für machen und so einen Twitter tippt man einfach ein.
Ja, alle deiner Celebrities mit dem RSS-Feed sind auch dabei hier. Siracusa zum Beispiel und irgendwie naja, meine ganzen Freunde und tralala und halt irgendwie.
Und es ist überschaubar, weil es nur 140 Zeichen sind. Da muss man sich beim Tippen echte Mühe geben und du hast halt eine Nachricht.
So SMS da.
Du kannst ja alles per SMS schicken lassen.
Du kannst ja auch alles per SMS schicken lassen.
Aber was man gleich dazu sagen muss, Twitter ist sagenhaft unstable, das ist bekannt. Trotzdem, es benutzen viele Leute. Sie haben irgendwie 200.000 aktive User pro Woche.
Das ist schon echt okay.
Und deswegen gibt es auch gar keine Twitter-Klien so richtig, weil man sich einfach auf seinen Jabbaklien subscribt.
Es gibt Twitterrific, was ganz hübsch ist. Windows-User.
Das Geld, aber es taucht.
Twitterrific gibt es auch in einer werbefinanzierten Version, genau. Das macht so wunderbare Geräusche. Ich kann es ja mal einschalten, wenn dir hier eine Nachricht kommt. Dein Vogelswitcher?
Guck mal hier, 343MAX, das ist nämlich hier unser Max, der schreibt hier, erklären Dennis im MM Podcast, was Twitter ist. Versuchen wir es zumindest.
Jetzt mach doch mal.
Ich glaube, Dennis nähert sich langsam dem Verständnis von Twitter. Was ist denn das für ein scheiß Satz?
Es gibt einen Kleinen, der heißt Twill. Da muss man irgendwo ein H einsetzen bei dem Namen.
Ich schreib das jetzt nicht, aber guck mal hier. Der da hat gerade auf seiner Tasse so das eingegeben und hier ist es. Ich sehe das sozusagen in Recent, weil er eben einer derjenigen ist, die ich fahre.
Und du lässt es nicht in deinen Jobber vorwarten.
Doch, ich hab meinen Jobber bloß gerade nie an.
Verstehe.
Der schickt mir das nur, wenn ich online bin. Also der schickt mir nicht irgendwie offline alles und wenn man dann online geht, kriegt man erstmal 500 Kilobyte Zeug, sondern das ist so, wie man sich das denkt. Aber das ist ganz nett, weil du hast auch noch eine Kommandozahle und du kannst mit Jobber etwas machen, was du im Web-Interface nicht machen kannst. Du kannst nämlich auch Begriffe tracken. Du kannst sagen, irgendwie Track, Mobile Max und dann, wenn irgendjemand was postet, wo Mobile Max drin ist, dann kriegst du das halt auch.
Egal wer wieder.
Egal wer. Und das ist echt interessant, weil damit kannst du so richtig auf keinen Fische reingehen. Genau. Das ist cool. Es gibt nämlich Leute, die tracken bestimmte Begriffe, auf die sie total abfahren. Ich hab mal einen Test gemacht. Ich hab mal was zur OpenID gefragt. So. Can anybody explain me how to set up an OpenID-Server? Zackretan. 21, 22, innerhalb der ersten 60 Sekunden hatte ich zwei Antworten mit konkreten Links. Von Leuten, von denen ich keine Ahnung habe, wer das war. Irgendwelche Amis.
Ich hab das auch mit getrackten Begriffen.
Das hab ich noch nirgendswo gehabt. Noch nicht mal im Usenet hab ich so eine Response gehabt.
Hab ich genau das Gleiche gehabt. Ich hab gestern irgendwie gefragt, kennt irgendjemand ein schönes Backup-Tool für Twitter? Weil die Nachrichten. Und hab dann von irgendeinem Holländer eine Antwort bekommen, der offensichtlich Backup und Twitter in einem Tweet trackt. Und der ist dann, das war, ja, und jetzt, ich hab's mal ausprobiert, das Tool. Scheint ganz cool zu sein. Weil langsam sind die Nachrichten doch so interessanter, die ich da habe, weil...
Also kann man aber schon generell sagen, dass auch dieses ganze Computer Internet-Zeugs geht immer mehr in Richtung noch schnellere, direktere Tools. Weil Twitter ist ja dann noch schneller als irgendwie ein Blog. Wie du ja schon sagtest. Beim Blog brauchen wir wieder einen Server und man muss irgendwie eintippen und Webseiten und das Twitter ist so zack direkt raus.
Es ist einfacher. Es ist wirklich eine sehr gute Abstraktion. Dieses Schneller finde ich jetzt nicht so wichtig, sondern es ist effizienter.
Es ist reduziert schön.
Weil du hast zum Beispiel im Vergleich zum normalen Chat, da hast du es immer mit diesen ganzen Leuten zu tun, die hängen immer nur im Chat ab und müssen dann auf die auch jeden Scheiß kommentieren. Und dann hast du immer bla bla bla bla Trollerei, Trollerei, Phase, ich baue mir in der Nase, hier lustiger Link, YouTube-Video und so weiter. Das hast du bei Twitter so nicht. Die Leute schreiben tendenziell eher relevantes. Tendenziell heißt, es gibt natürlich Leute, die sind so ein bisschen mehr so Plappertaschen-mäßig, kannst du ja irgendwie Cosmos abschreiben, kannst du irgendwie alles schön ausführlich dargestellt, aber das gehört auch irgendwie dazu. Gibt es Leute, die eigentlich nur Sinnvolles machen und so ist halt die Mischung wie im richtigen Leben. Aber im Vergleich zu einem normalen Chat, der ja auch viel enger gefasst ist, thematisch in der Regel, ist es halt weniger. Und es ist auch weniger im Vergleich zur Bloggerei. Also du würdest Sachen, ich twittere Sachen, die ich nicht bloggen würde. Trotzdem ist es halt im Web und es ist verlinkbar und du kannst ein RSS-Feed davon abonnieren. Also es ist auch schon so wie Bloggen. Und es füllt einfach eine Lücke. Also es ist irgendwo etwas, was nicht Bloggen ist und was nicht Chatten ist, aber von all dem so die Essenz erbt. Und das macht Twitter schon zu einem Dienst, der wirklich was Neues ist. Und man sieht auch, dass Twitter wird halt auch extrem angenommen, weil es eben auch sehr leicht in Webseiten mit reinzubringen ist. Also es gibt diverse Sites, so Web 2.0-Anwendungen und so weiter, die nehmen das. Ich glaube, Xing hat irgendwie auch eine Twitter-Funktion mittlerweile. Du, ich glaube, Mogulus, Ustream, Ustream macht Java und Mogulus macht Twitter. Ich weiß es jetzt gerade nicht.
Hier Quick oder wie das heißt, die twittern auch so ein bisschen rum.
Auf jeden Fall, Websites bauen es einfach ein, weil es sind sowieso schon alle in Twitter. Alle außer Dennis. Alle außer Dennis sind derzeit irgendwie, wenn wir wieder zahlreiche Leute haben, die sagen, ich weiß nicht.
Probiert es aus, es macht süchtig. Und irgendwann ist es auch wieder vorbei. Das iPhone Black gibt es übrigens doch nicht. Das hat gerade ein Sprecher von AT&T gesagt. Tut uns leid. Das ist aber Fake, behaupten sie.
Steve hat ihn geprügelt.
Steve hat ja auch schon mal gesagt, niemand will Video auf dem iPod.
Ja, als wir noch kein Video auf dem iPod konnten. Hallo, was solltet ihr noch anderes sagen?
Ja genau, das ist wie Steve Jobs Kommentar zu dem Amazon Kindle, der irgendwie meinte, ich habe ein Video auf dem iPod. In Amerika liest keiner. Und dann hat hier John Gruber das kommentiert und das könnte zwei Sachen bedeuten. Entweder niemand liest Bücher in Amerika oder zweitens Apple ist working on a secret product. Das ist einfach alles so lange mit, das will doch keiner kommentieren, bis sie selber ein Produkt rausbringen.
Ja klar, die dürfen ja nicht sagen, was als next cool Item rauskommt.
Ich glaube, sie waren aber selber ein bisschen überrascht von dem Video-Erfolg mit dem iPod. Also, das ist schon eine realistische Einschätzung. Also, keine realistische, sondern realistisch ihre Einschätzung war, dass sie der Meinung waren, dass Video da nichts zu suchen hat, aber...
Bin ich bis heute ein bisschen der Meinung. Ich hab neulich mal probiert, auf dem iPhone Video zu gucken. Ich hab so eine Cinemizer-Brille. Kennt ihr das Ding? Das ist von Carl Zeiss heißt das, das ist so eine kleine Brille. Die haben so Testgeräte rumgeschrieben. Ich hab die mir zuschicken lassen als Testgerät. Ich bin ein ausgewählter Test-User. Soll ich das nächste Woche mal mitbringen?
Natürlich.
Das bringt man über Podcasts relativ schlecht. Das ist so eine Brille, die setzt man sich auf. Wenn man in einem Zug definitiv nur von Polizeibeamten angesprochen werden möchte, dann setzt man sich diese Brille auf. Weil man sieht aus wie... Genauso gut kann man sich nackt hinsetzen. Es sieht richtig scheiße aus, aber man hat da so zwei kleine Displays drin und kann darüber Filme gucken. Das schließt man dann an sein iPhone oder an sein iPod an.
Das geht auch nur mit dem iPhone oder iPod?
Das geht auch nur mit dem iPhone oder iPod im Augenblick. Man kann so einen Adapterkabel kaufen und dann kann man es auch irgendwie an einen VIA-Anschluss anschließen oder so. Aber es ist eindeutig gedacht für iPhone und iPod. Für iPhone noch nicht richtig, weil da haben sie noch keine Genehmigung von Apple für, aber die anderen sind alle entsprechende Adapter dabei und das passt und es geht alles ganz super. Und was kostet das? Das kostet irgendwie so 300 Euro. Ich würds mir aber auf jeden Fall vorher angucken, weil die Bildqualität ist schon relativ lausig. Und zwar nicht mal was die Auflösung unbedingt angeht, sondern was das Bild angeht, das könnte ruhig deutlich besser sein.
Ich hab das auch im Test gelesen, die meinen, das ist schon so ein cooler Anfang, aber da geht noch mehr.
Aber was grandios ist, sich abends ins Bett zu legen, Decke über den Kopf zu ziehen. Im Winter wäre es ganz geil, vor einem Film zu gucken. Das hat was sehr Eigenes, sich schön auf die Seite zu kuscheln. Nur die Augen darf man nicht beizumachen, was am Anfang wirklich ein bisschen gewöhnungsbedürftig ist. Aber ansonsten ist es die direkte Vorstufe zum geschlossenen Augenfemme gucken.
Ich hab mir mal den Test gemacht und mir mal Blade Runner The Final Cut, da gibt es jetzt diesen 25 Jahre Edition, weiß schon, den letzten Schliff, angeguckt. Und zwar einmal auf dem iPod und einmal auf dem iPhone. Das iPhone hat ja die doppelte Auflösung. Das iPod hat 320x240 und das iPhone hat 480x320 und so was. Und dann will man auf dem iPod gar nicht mehr hingucken. Das geht einfach nicht.
Das befürchte ich auch, dass das dann auch der Effekt ist. Aber so bin ich noch ganz zufrieden.
Westernworld fragt gerade, ob der Podcast noch weiter online geht. Das bringt jetzt gar nichts, das so zu beantworten.
Das bringt überhaupt nichts. Das bringt überhaupt nichts. Die Antwort ist ein entschiedenes keine Ahnung.
Dann check ich exakt das zurück.
Weiß ich noch nicht. Ich bin schon ein bisschen viel Autobahn gefahren heute. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das jetzt noch fertig mache. Spätestens morgen.
Wir können jetzt ja gerade sagen, in der Tschechischen Slowakei?
Habe ich das gesagt? In Tschechien. Da war ich in der Zeit unterwegs. Ich habe eine Zeitreise unternommen. Mit der Time Capsule. Ha ha, kahl aber.
Den Witz hast du mitgebracht, ne?
Jetzt sind wir fast durch. Wir nähern uns schon an unserer Standardlänge von 1,40. Auf die es immer irgendwie hinausläuft, finde ich. Keine Ahnung warum. Das ist die alte 100 Minuten. 100 heiße Minuten. 100 heiße Minuten, das ist doch mal gut. Ich habe mich immer gewundert, warum es 1,40 ist. Du wolltest dir aber noch, wir hatten vorhin noch ein interessantes Thema, das haben wir jetzt bis zum Ende aufgehoben. Du brauchst eine neue Laptop-Schasche.
Ich brauche eine Laptop-Schasche.
Laptop-Beutelchen.
Genau, ich brauche keine neue.
Eine alte brauchst du.
Ich bin mit meiner sehr glücklich. Ich habe hier so eine Crumpler-Tasche, aber die müsste jetzt mal gewaschen werden. Ja, aber in der Zeit bin ich ja quasi an mein Haus gebunden.
Du willst sie mal waschen, dann brauchst du jetzt eine neue.
Die ist in fünf Minuten trocken, die Dinge.
Wie dreckig ist sie denn? Willst du sie erst mal in irgendwas einlegen oder was?
Und es gibt hier diese großartige von BILD, B-U-I-L-T, BILD New York. Ich krieg da kein...
Ach, so klug sind wir ja gar nicht, dass wir hier Affiliate-Tings machen. Das könnten wir mal machen. Wir könnten reich werden. BILD, was? Sag mal die Url.
BILD, B-U-I-L-T, New York, ny.com.
In einem Wort.
In einem Wort, hintereinander weg. Das ging so ein bisschen rum. Das sieht so ein bisschen aus wie so eine...
So eine Weste, die vorne wenig Stoff hat. Und hinten ganz viel Stoff. Und da kann man halt dein Laptop reinstecken. Also so was eng Anliegenes könnte man sagen.
Und ich finde das ziemlich grandios.
Das sieht aber echt aus, als ob du, wenn du damit in den USA rumläufst, sofort verhaftet wirst.
Ich hab nicht vor damit in den USA rumzulaufen, sondern in Berlin. Und hier wird man damit sofort verhaftet.
Was ist denn das? Was sind denn das alles? Was haben die denn da? Was ist denn das?
Das kostet irgendwie 80 Euro.
Das ist nicht nur so eine Laptop-Tasche. Die machen hier irgendwie Placemats und irgendwie Weinflaschenöffner.
Ich weiß nicht, was die alles noch so treiben.
Baby-Lätzchen haben die auch.
Baby-Lätzchen.
I want one.
Also nicht so richtig spezialisiert.
Ich brauch kein Lätzchen mehr.
Aber für fünf Minuten reicht's, oder?
Ich hab ja hier so einen East-Pack-Rucksack, wo man das Laptop von der Seite reinsteckt, was eigentlich ganz praktisch ist, weil man muss nicht die Haupttasche benutzen. Man macht an der Seite so einen Reißverschluss aus, schiebt das rein, hat sogar noch zwei Schneiden. Das Problem war, dass ich mal losgerannt bin an der Uraniburger, wollte mir einen Taxi rufen, hab dabei den Arm gehoben und hatte aber irgendwie die Tasche nicht zugemacht.
Und dann wird das Ding einfach so ejectet, wie so eine Diske.
Dann ist mir mein 15 Zoll MBP rausgefallen und fett auf die Kante.
Das find ich ja super an diesen Teilen. Wenn sie dann mal runterfallen, dieses Alu fängt einfach den Stoss, oder?
Das Ding war im Schlafmodus, das Display ist aufgesprungen, dann war er einfach an. Ich hab ihn wieder zugemacht, bin weitergefahren und ich musste nicht mal booten. Das könnt ihr posten, ihr braucht wahrscheinlich ein bisschen mehr Licht.
Hier ist Licht.
Also mein nächster Anspruch an eine Laptoptasche wäre, dass man sie nicht von der Seite reinsteckt, sondern von oben, weil da kann man es dann auch mal offen lassen und es passiert nichts.
Oder noch mal zum eigenen Schlüpfer. Aber das halte ich eigentlich für Quatsch. Ich hätte eigentlich auch lieber nur so Laptop rein und fertig.
Diese Schlüpfer extra, diese, wie für die Leute, diese eng anliegenden Täschchen, wo es noch mal drin ist und das dann in den Rucksack rein, brauche ich eigentlich gar nicht. Weil im Rucksack ist es schon relativ sicher und wenn es da nicht sicher ist, dann hilft dieser Schlüpfer da auch nichts mehr.
Schlüpfer ist eigentlich nur, wenn du sozusagen es mit Schlüpfer rausnimmst und dann noch mal separat trägst, aber das will man ja eigentlich auch nicht.
Das ist ganz praktisch, wenn sich so der Dreck im Laufe der Zeit in der Tasche ansammelt. Also sammeln sie sich ja gerne Krümel an.
Du sollst jetzt deine Tasche mal waschen.
Krümel, aha, jetzt kommen wir langsam zum Kern des Problems.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Aber wenn du eine dedizierte Laptop-Tasche hast, die einen eigenen Ritzer hat.
Auch da sammeln sich im Laufe der Zeit. Ich weiß nicht, wo du was hast.
Also ich hätte ganz andere Anforderungen. Ich hab ja auch schon seit Jahren, ich schau immer wieder, ich finde nichts. Ich kann mich auch nicht entscheiden. Was ich ja eigentlich am interessantesten finde, sind diese, wie heißt die auch? Ich vergess jedes Mal wieder. Nee, was Huckel hat.
Ach so, ja, hab ich vergessen.
Das Ding ist großartig.
Nee, aber viel zu fett.
Ja, es ist fett.
Der ist immer auf volle Größe. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ich find's raus. Aber der ist immer auf volle Größe und kann sich nicht so anpassen, wenn er mal nicht voll ist.
Ich kann jetzt mal kurz zwischendurch erzählen, ich war mit Tim letztes Jahr auf der IFA. Und wir kamen an den Crumpler, das ist ein australischer Laptoptaschenhersteller vorbei, unter anderem stellen die Laptoptaschen her im Wesentlichen. Ungefähr 48.000 verschiedene Modelle. Und Tim blieb gefühlte acht Stunden an dem Stand stehen und beackerte das Standpersonal, dass sie doch bitte mal einen Rucksack nach seinen Wünschen herstellen sollten. Und ich glaube, er hatte am Ende das Personal soweit, dass sie ihm zugestimmt haben und sehr schnell nach Australien zurückgeflüchtet sind. Das war schon sehr beeindruckend, was Tim sich für... Achso, nein, sie haben ja empfohlen, eine eigene Laptoptaschenhersteller aufzumachen.
Vielleicht sollte ich das auch wirklich tun, aber ich meine, ich bin mir am Ende des Tages auch immer nicht so richtig sicher, was ich eigentlich will. Aber ich hatte so verschiedene Erfolgsmodelle. Was ich zum Beispiel, was mir leider mit meinem Laptop geklaut wurde, war die Tasche. Und die war so simpel. Das war einfach eine Tasche. Du machst den Deckel auf und dann hast du drei große, gleich große Compartments. Sowas von toll. Das war super einfach zu konfigurieren. Da hatte ich den Rechner immer noch in seinem eigenen Schlupfer drin. Und den dann halt da reingetan. Aber super, weil die waren sehr dehnungsfähig. Und dann konntest du halt irgendwie Pullover reinstecken. Und du hattest immer so eine Tasche für Rechnerkram, eine Tasche für großes Zeug, eine für kleines Zeug. Aber was ich eigentlich lieber hätte, wäre auch wirklich etwas, was stabil ist, was wirklich gut ist.
Was denn? Dennis ist Spaces-Benutzer. Habe ich das gerade richtig gesehen?
Klar.
Der benutzt Spaces.
Du bist der erste, den ich kennenlerne, der das wirklich benutzt.
Na, ich mach mit...
Ist die Laptop-Taschen-Diskussion beendet?
Nein, nein, nein.
Aber ich mach das halt bestimmte Programme in bestimmten Spaces kommen. Also Mail und iTunes zum Beispiel kommen immer in einem anderen Space.
Da müssen wir eben zunächst mal das Hirn zerlegen und sezieren und rauskriegen.
Die Sachen mit Spaces müssen wir auf jeden Fall auch nochmal nachholen. Aber bei Laptop-Taschen, ehrlich gesagt, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, was ich sagen soll. Ich hätte einfach gerne mal was Cooles. Vielleicht können ja mal unsere, vielleicht sollten wir mal was bloggen.
Nochmal dazu ein paar Themen. Also ich hatte mal...
Dass die Leute mal sagen, was sie so...
In Anforderungen sind.
Was cool ist.
Also ich hab ja irgendwie drei Taschen, eine fürs Laptop von der Seite und zwei so von oben. Ist irgendwie auch ganz cool. Aber als Computer-Benutzer hat man ja immer so kleine Scheiße, eine kleine Festplatte und dann hast du ein paar Kabel, dann hast du einen Adapter. Dafür brauch ich viele kleine Taschen. Und damit ich genau weiß, alles klar, mein irgendwie DVI- oder VGA-Adapter, der ist immer genau in der Tasche rechts unten oder da in der Mitte oder irgendwie so. Und ich hab halt gerade nur so ein oder zwei. Und das ist ein bisschen zu wenig. Da flattert immer alles rum und zerkratzt und so. Das ist auch noch so eine Sache. Willst du mal ein iPod transportieren oder ein iPhone? Ich will nicht immer so Täschchen haben. Man muss immer einpacken und auspacken, das nervt. Und dann will ich so einzelne Täschchen haben, wo ich so reinmachen kann, ein bisschen kratziger.
Ich finde ja ein iPhone und ein iPod, der muss nach einer Weile schon ein bisschen zerkratzt auch sein. Das ist so ein Ausflug-Effekt.
Mir ist ja auch mein iPhone schon runtergefallen.
Mein iPhone hab ich auch mal das erste Mal runtergeschmissen.
Vielleicht habt ihr das Update nicht mehr.
Nee, das hat andere Gründe.
Das hat hier so einen kleinen schwarzen Schlag jetzt. Das muss so ein Gerät auch gebraucht werden.
Hier riecht es nach Essen jetzt.
Ah ja, wir waren bei Laptop Talk.
Okay, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Wir müssen das Thema jetzt auch langsam beenden. Vielleicht können wir das beim nächsten Mal auch nochmal aufgreifen mit den Laptop Taschen. Ich finde das eigentlich ganz interessant.
Das ist ja quasi die Ankündigungssendung.
Worüber wir alles schon einmal reden wollten.
Also lieber Hörer, eure Hausaufgaben für heute. Mal erzählen, was ihr für tolle Taschen habt.
Ich habe auch noch eine Bitte an den Hörer. Bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte. Wenn ihr Fragen habt zu bestimmten Themen, und wir sollen mal was erklären, dann könnt ihr das vielleicht auch nochmal machen. Heute haben wir mal über Unix geredet. Vielleicht ist das auch noch etwas, was mehr Fragen aufbringt. Jungsler, Command Line, definitiv sind wir immer gerne dabei.
Das macht sich auch immer abgesprochen so super.
Und wir könnten natürlich Vorschläge zu Laptop-Taschen ganz gut gebrauchen. Vielleicht diskutieren wir dann einfach mal ein paar von den Sachen, die da kommen. Schauen uns die mal an, was wir daran gut finden und nicht. Ist natürlich immer mit dem Ausprobieren, dem Angucken im Web so eine Sache. Ich muss auch unbedingt nochmal nachschlagen, wie diese, wie heißt denn dieser Rucksack?
Offline? Nein, doch er ist online, aber reagiert nicht.
Das ist eine.
Horrible. Das sind die Schlimmsten.
Das sind die Schlimmsten.
Wofür handelt der Internet?
Na gut, uns gehen die Themen auf jeden Fall nicht aus. Ich würd sagen, das war's.
Weißt du nicht, die ERO heißt oder so was?
Nee. Was, der Rucksack?
Ich dachte, der trifft dazu.
Doesn't ring a bell ist anders. Das wird auch von so einer bekloppten Motorradfirma in Deutschland vertrieben. Deswegen sind die Webseiten auch so furchtbar. Ist auch egal, wir kommen noch drauf. Machen wir einen Abgesang?
Machen wir einen Abgesang.
Okay, dann haben wir uns gefreut, dass wir wieder Zuhörer hatten. Bis zum Ende. Wir haben zwar Nummer vier, Nummer fünf kommt.
In circa zwei Wochen.
In circa zwei Wochen. Diesmal waren wir ja relativ pünktlich. Nicht schlecht, oder?
Ja, aber das wird schon alles klappen. Das ist so ungeschnitten rausgegeben.
Natürlich ist das ungeschnitten.
Na dann raus damit.
Ja, aber ich muss ja auch noch sagen, worüber es ist. Und da ich so involviert bin, dass immer so eine Aufflangung und Diskussionskultur ist.
Wir brauchen jetzt wieder eine Stunde für diesen Titel. Hat er ja am Anfang der Sendung schon gesagt.
Ja, das ist bei Twitter das Geile.
Könntest du mir jetzt die fünf Sachen sagen, über die wir im Kern geredet haben? Dinge. Staffet Expander muss sterben sind vier Worte.
Twitter ist ja auch die vierte Sache.
Und schon haben wir es rein damit und fertig.
Twitter Doppelpunkt, Staffet Expander muss sterben. Wir werden es veralbern. Tschüss.